PROTECT THE PUBLIC AND
LEGISLATORS AND EMPLOYES WE
MUST SIT HERE TO SOCIAL
DISTANCING GUIDELINES. IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS THE
SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THE
PUBLIC CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS
TO THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS WE'RE
HOLDING OUR COMMITTEE HEARINGS
HERE IN THE CAPITAL AND I ASK
ALL MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE TO
BE PRESENT IN ROOM FORTY TWO ALL
THREE SO WE CAN STOP THE
CORPSMAN BEGIN OUR HEARING. TO
ALLOW PUBLIC ACCESS WE HAVE A
MINUTE MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC IN
THE HEARING ROOM TO THE EXTENT
THE SOCIAL DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS ALLOW IT WILL BE
USING A TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WAS TO
TESTIFY TODAY. FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE.
PUBLIC COMMENT THE PARTICIPANT
TOLL FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS CODE
IS POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. IT WILL BE DISPLAYED ON
THE SCREEN AND I WILL ANNOUNCE
IT NOW TODAY'S PARTICIPANT
NUMBER IS EIGHT FOUR FOUR. TWO
NINE ONE SIX THREE SIX FOUR.
EIGHT FOUR FOUR TWO NINE ONE SIX
THREE SIX FOR. AN ACCESS CODE IS. ONE FOUR ONE ONE ONE FOUR
ZERO. AGAIN. ONE FOUR ONE ONE
ONE FOUR ZERO FOR DETAILED DISH
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW THE
TELECONFERENCES TO MARCH PLEASE
REFER TO THE SENATE. WAR
COMMITTEE WEBSITE- WHEN WE MOVED
TO PUBLIC COMMENT YOU WILL BE
PROMPTED BY A MODERATOR TO DOUBT
ONE. THEN ZERO FOR SUPPORT. AND
OPPOSITION PRESSES ONLY ONE TIME
AND WAIT PATIENTLY FOR OPERATOR
TO ASSIGN YOU A LINE NUMBER THIS
CAN TAKE A SHORT TIME. SURE LOW
WEIGHT SO BE PATIENT WANT TO
RECEIVE YOUR ONLINE NUMBER YOU
WILL WAIT IN QUEUE FOR THE
MODERATOR TO CALL YOUR NUMBER.
AT THAT TIME YOU WILL BE MUTE
UNMUTE IT AND YOU YOU'LL BE NOW
READY TO ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE.
PLEASE NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR US
TO HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND AVOID
ANY ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK YOU MUST
MUTE THE DEVICE YOU ARE WATCHING
HEARING ON PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY OVER THE FALL IT IS
IMPORTANT WE HEAR. FROM YOU AND
WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE
HI- WILL MAINTAIN DECORUM AT
THIS HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY AND
ANY INDIVIDUAL WHO IS DISRUPTIVE
MAY BE REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE
MEETING SERVICES ARE HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED. OUT WE HAVE
FIVE BILLS ON THE AGENDA TODAY
S. B. EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN BITES-
CENTER ACT EGGMAN IS NOT
CONSIDERED- BEFORE WE HEAR
BILLS- PRESENTATIONS WE WILL
STOP TO QUORUM. WHEN ANSWER
COUNCIL TO CALL THE ROLL.
BRADFORD BRADFORD HERE A CHAU
BOOK. TROUBLE HERE COM LONGER
SKINNER WINNER. WINNER HERE
QUORUM IS ESTABLISHED WE HAVE A
QUORUM AND OUR FIRST AUTHOR UP
HIS SKINNER EGGMAN AND SHE'LL BE
PRESENTING- S. B. EIGHT EIGHT
TWO CENTER EGGMAN FORESHORES
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS I'M PRESENTING THIS
MORNING EIGHT EIGHT TWO AND I'D
LIKE TO THANK THE COMMITTEE FOR
WORKING WITH MY OFFICE ON SOME
CLARIFYING AMENDMENTS REGARDING
THE AGENCY NAME MAKING LANGUAGE
CONSISTENT AND HELPING BALANCE
THE APPOINTMENTS REQUIRED BY
THIS BILL. THE GOAL OF THIS BILL
IS TO CREATE AS A GROUP OF
STAKEHOLDERS AND EXPERTS TO
REVIEW AND EVALUATE THE
INTERVENTIONS AND TRAININGS-
THAT LAW ENFORCEMENT AND PUBLIC
AND THE POLICE DEPARTMENT USES A
TO INTERVENE WITH PEOPLE FACING
I. D. AND D. D. AND OTHER KINDS
OF MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES- IDEALLY
LAW ENFORCEMENT ARE NOT THE
FIRST ONES ON THE SCENE WORKING
WITH THESE KINDS OF INDIVIDUALS
BUT WE KNOW THAT STILL OVERALL.
THEY ARE THE FIRST ONES
RESPONDING OUT AND SOMETIMES NO
MATTER WHO ARE NEW SYSTEMS WHAT
RESPONDING TO SOME KIND OF
CRISIS WE KNOW LAW ENFORCEMENT
WILL CONTINUE TO HAVE A ROLE- WE
ALSO KNOW THAT UP TO ONE HALF TO
ONE THIRD OF INTERACTIONS THAT
LAW ENFORCEMENT PUBLIC SAFETY
RESPONSE TO END UP IN SOMEBODY
BEING HURT. WE ALSO KNOW THAT
LAW ENFORCEMENT DOES NOT WANT TO
BE OUT HURTING PEOPLE AND IN
FACT WOULD LIKE BETTER TOOLS AND
WHILE THOSE TRAININGS THROUGH
POST IN EVERY COUNTRY THINGS
LIKE THAT- THE BELIEF ISWE
REALLY NEED TO HAVE BETTER BEST
PRACTICES KIND OF EVALUATE WHAT
TYPES OF INTERVENTIONS ARE BEING
USED- WHAT COULD BE BETTER AND
HOW THEN THOSE ARE DISSEMINATED-
SO THIS BILL WILL DOCUMENT.
THOSE TYPES OF INTERACTIONS
EXAMINE WHAT WORKS WHAT DOESN'T
WHAT ME NEED TO BE IMPROVED- TO
BE ABLE TO REALLY MAKE SURE THAT
WE ARE MEETING PEOPLE WHERE THEY
ARE BEING ABLE TO INTERVENE
APPROPRIATELY GETTING PEOPLE TO-
THE RIGHT RESOURCES AND- NOBODY
GETTING HURT IN THE PROCESS ON
THE I. D. D. D. OR FOLKS STARK
STRUGGLING WITH MENTAL HEALTH
ISSUES. BUT I HAVE TO WITNESSES
WERE ME TO WRITE TESTIMONY IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. JORDAN
EXECUTIVE OF THE ARK OF
CALIFORNIA. AND ONE OF MY
CONSTITUENTS ESTROGEN I GOT FROM
SHE'S EXECUTIVE VICE PRESIDENT.
OF U. D. W. THANK YOU WILL
PROVIDE A TO MANAGE TO EACH A
WITNESS IN SUPPORT OF FORMAN'S
TOTAL SO. IF YOU'RE FIRST WHEN
WITNESSES PREPARED YOU MAY BEGIN
YOUR TESTIMONY NOW. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR THE TO JORDAN AND
THE WITH THE ARK OF CALIFORNIA
I'M GOING TO DEFER MY TWO MINUTE
ASTRID THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU AND GOOD MORNING
CHAIRMAN AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS I
APPRECIATE YOU TAKING THE TIME
TODAY TO HEAR FROM ME- AGAIN MY
NAME IS DR. I AM THE EXECUTIVE
VICE PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
DOMESTIC WORKERS AND IN HOME
CARE PROVIDER AND ADVOCATE FOR.
MY ADULT CHILD MANNY- MANUAL BUT
MOST PEOPLE KNOWN AS MANY AS
TWENTY THREE YEARS OLD. HE LIVES
WITH AUTISM INTELLECTUAL
DISABILITIES AND EPILEPSY. I DON
AND NUMBER. AND HE NEEDS ROUND
THE CLOCK SUPERVISION. AND ADDED
CARE GIVER I MUST MAINTAIN A
CONSTANT STATE OF VIGILANCE TO
PROTECT HIM FROM HARM. HE IS A
FIGHT BACK. HAVE NO FEAR OF
WATER HI ARE YOU CAN RUN INTO
TRAFFIC FOR HIS HAND ON THE
STOVE- OR WORK- I'VE HAD THE
FEARS OF HIM POTENTIALLY HAVING
INTERACTIONS WITH SOMEONE WHO
DOESN'T UNDERSTAND HIM. IF THAT
PERSON I POLICE DOCTOR A COUNTER
COULD HAVE BEEN FATAL MY HAS MY
SON. FOLLOW VERBAL COMMANDS HE
HAS HIS BASIC INSTINCT IS TO
FIGHT OR FLIGHT- AND THIS IS
JUST NOT NEEDING AN
OVERPROTECTIVE MOM THIS IS THE
REALITY FOR MANY- THE PARENTS
AND CAREGIVERS IN CALIFORNIA AND
ACROSS THE STATE. WHO HAVE A
LOVED ONE LIKE MY FAN OR- ARE
MAIENSCHEIN. RESEARCH AT THE
SENATORS THAT HAS SHOWN THAT ONE
THIRD ONE HALF OF PEOPLE. TOLD
BY POLICE ARE PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES. AND IN MANY CASES
THE DISABILITY IS AN
INTELLECTUAL DEVELOPMENTAL OR
WILL ON THAT. WE DON'T HAVE
GREAT WE'VE DONE SOME REALLY
GREAT WORK HERE IN CALIFORNIA
REGION AWARENESS. OF THE
DISTRESS THAT THE PROMOTION IT.
STANDARDS LOOK AT FACE WHEN
INTERACTING WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT
. TWENTY NINETEEN FOR INSTANCE
CALIFORNIA PASSED EIGHTY NINE
ONE ONE BUT MANY OTHER ACT WHICH
WAS NAMED AFTER MY SON. MANY
ALERT ACT WITH A CRUCIAL FIRST
STEP TOWARDS MAKING SURE FIRST
RESPONDERS HAD IMPORTANT
INFORMATION ABOUT PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES AND ADVANCED
EMERGENCY. WHAT STILL NEEDS TO
BE IMPLEMENTED BUT WE'LL SAVE
THAT CONVERSATION FOR ANOTHER
DAY- NOW. HOWEVER WE NEED TO
PUSH FORWARD- WITH THE SENATE
BILL EIGHTY TWO. BY CREATING
THIS AD ADVISORY COUNCIL WITHIN
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL'S OFFICE.
ALSO WOULD BE ABLE TO EVALUATE
THE EXISTING RESOURCES AVAILABLE
TO LAW ENFORCEMENT. INCLUDING
THE TRAINING PERTAINING TO
INTERACTIONS WITH PEOPLE LIVING
WITH INTELLECTUAL AND
DEVELOPMENTAL AND OR MENTAL
ILLNESSES. AND MAKE THESE
RECOMMENDATIONS. AND
ADDITIONALLY WOULD ALSO IMPROVE
THE USE OF FORCE RECORDING-
INCLUDING WHETHER THAT
INDIVIDUAL HAD AN INTELLECTUAL
OR DEVELOPMENTAL OR MENTAL
HOUSEKEEPING AREN'T. OKAY NOW IT
WOULD ONLY HELP BUT IN WITH LONG
FOR AND MOVING FORWARD. TO HAVE
THESE DISCUSSIONS AND EVERYBODY
. BE AT THAT TABLE TO MAKE SURE
THAT AT THE END OF THE DAY
EVERYBODY IS GOING HOME SAFELY
TO THEIR LOVED ONES AND AT THE
SENATORS THAT ARE LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS IN NO WAY
SHAPE OR FORM WANT. TO HURT
SOMEBODY WHO HAS A DEVELOPMENTAL
OR INTELLECTUAL DISABILITY
HOWEVER. THE UNKNOWN ARE THERE
AND IF WE CAN ONLY HELP THEM DO
THEIR JOB. WE CAN COLLECTIVELY
MAKE SURE AGAIN THAT EVERYBODY
COME HOME SAFELY. AND- THAT IS
WHY SB EIGHTY TWO IF NECESSARY
AND THE NEXT STEP. IN OUR STATE
GOALS OF PROTECTING PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES AND THE
INTERACTIONS AND ON BEHALF OF
THE OVER HUNDRED FIFTY FIVE
THOUSAND HOME CARE WORKERS IN MY
UNION AND CHILD CARE FOR.
WRITERS PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES
THAT WE CARE FOR I URGE YOU TO
PASS SB EIGHT EIGHTY TWO THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR TIME
TODAY THANK YOU ISN'T A GOOD FOR
YOUR ATTENTION. AND YES I
APOLOGIZE. I BUDGET MAKING SURE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE- WITH A
LITTLE TIME LEFT- YOUR NINETY
WITH THE ART CALIFORNIA WE
REPRESENTS AND ARE LED BY
PARENTS OF INDIVIDUALS WITH
INTELLECTUAL DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES IN CALIFORNIA AND
WE'RE VERY GRATEFUL THAT ARE
GOING TO BRING THIS BILL FORD
AND ASTRID- CLEARLY LAID OUT
THAT IT'S A CONCERN FOR MANY IF
NOT ALL PARENTS OF INDIVIDUALS-WITH DEVELOP DISABILITIES MENTAL
HEALTH CHALLENGES. AND WE ARE
VERY GRATEFUL AGAIN. AND WE URGE
YOUR SUPPORT OF THE BILL. THANK
YOU. EMAIL WILL MOVE TO ANYONE
WISHING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
HERE IN- ROOM FORTY TWO OR A
THREE IS THERE ANYONE HERE IN
SUPPORT OF. S. B. EIGHT EIGHT
TWO. UNION SEEN NINE NOW WILL
MOVE TO OUR PHONE LINES
MODERATOR TO WE HAVE WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT IN Q. WISHING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB EIGHT
EIGHT TWO. MODERATOR. YOUR
MODERATOR THE BILL. YES SORRY I
WAS MUTED LADIES AND GENTLEMAN
ON THE PHONE LINES IF YOU WISH
TO OUR MAKE PUBLIC COMMENT TODAY
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY THE
ZERO A. T. T. OPERATOR QUICKLY
GIVE YOUR LINE NUMBER OFFLINE
THEN PLEASE WRITE BACK IN THE
QUEUE PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME FOR PUBLIC COMMENT.
WILL BEGIN TODAY WITH WIND
TWENTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
TWENTY FOUR YOU ARE ONLY. TWENTY
FOUR CAN YOU HEAR US. GOOD
MORNING I'M SORRY- WE CALDWELL
HOUSTON FOR THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS. BY TWENTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
MISTER CHAIR MY NAME IS FOR HER
AND I'M AN AGENT PROVIDER WITH
UW MERCED COUNTY SB EIGHT EIGHT
Q. IS A BILL THAT WOULD HELP
PROTECT I HAVE CLIENTS WITH
DISABILITIES FROM ADVERSE
INTERACTIONS WITH LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK. YOUR YES VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THANKS THIS. NINE
THIRTY YOU ARE OPEN. I THINK IN
THERE WITH THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER AND WE ARE IN
SUPPORT OF SB EIGHTY TWO. THANK
YOU NEXT WITNESS. ONE SEVENTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING-
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS CHRIS AT
STROM I AM I JUST SAYS PROVIDER-
AND- YOU W. WITH UW CARING FOR
MY CLIENT WAS ALSO- AUTISTIC NON
VERBAL- AND- PREMIERE IN MADERA-
THAT PLEASE- SUPPORT- SB EIGHT
EIGHT TWO- TO HELP EDUCATE OUR
COMMUNITY AND- KEEP OUR LOVED
ONES SAFE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS. MISTER CHAIR THERE
ARE NO OTHER PARTICIPANTS QUEUED
UP AT THIS TIME. GREAT OKAY NOW
WE'RE GONNA MOVE TO OPPOSITION
WE HAVE NO A LISTED NOT
TESTIMONY IN OPPOSITION AND WE
WILL SEE IF THERE'S ANYONE HERE
AND ROOM FORTY TWO OLD THREE WHO
WISHES TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION.
TO SB EIGHT EIGHT TWO. HEARING
SEEN NONE MODERATOR NOW WILL GO
TO THE PHONE LINES ARE ARE ARE
THERE ANYONE IN Q. WHOSE WISHING
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO SB
EIGHT EIGHT TWO. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR- PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION AT THIS TIME AND WE
WILL GO TO LIKE TWENTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THAT'S GOOD
MORNING SURE NUMBER ERIC
HARASSMENT DISTILLERY CALIFORNIA
WE ARE NOT IN OPPOSITION W JUST
HAVE. CONCERNS THAT WE WANTED TO
BOYS- REALLY BRIEFLY- CALIFORNIA
MORE THAN THEY- REPORT. OF TO
LONG MANAGED. THE RAINING BAND-
BEEN OPTION AND THEN LANGUAGE IN
THIS- ONLY TRAINING MENTION OF-
THAT BILL RECCA HAS HAD CONGRESO
WITH ON AND SPONSOR- ABOUT THE
HI AND THEY HAVE SAID THAT THEY
WOULD- MAKE SURE- THAT
ALTERNATIVES ARE ALSO INCLUDED
AND THE LANGUAGE BECAUSE-
ULTIMATELY- THEY WANT WHAT IS
WHAT IS THE BEST OPTION NOT ONLY
TRAINING BUT ANY OTHER POTENTIAL
OPTIONS AS WELL- AND THEN I
CAN'T. WILL BRIEFLY- ARE ONE OF
OUR CONCERNS INVOLVED SO- THE
MAKE UP OF THIS- COMMITTEE- WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT PEOPLE
WITH DISABILITIES ESPECIALLY
INTELLECTUAL OR DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES AS WELL AS MENTAL
HEALTH DISABILITY ARE INCLUDED
AND HAVE MORE- GUARANTEED WHAT
ENDED- COMMITTEE RIGHT NOW THERE
ARE ONLY TWO SLOTS AVAILABLE OR
TO START GUARANTEED OF FOR
SOMEBODY WITH AN INTELLECTUAL
AND DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITY OR
SOMEBODY WITH A MENTAL HEALTH
DISABILITY AND FROM OUR
STANDPOINT. THE HOW THE MAJORITY
OF PEOPLE- A MENTOR HEALTH
DISABILITY TORRENT FOR GOODBYE
TO IT WOULD BE NO THERE THAN
HAVE A POP OR COMMITTEE THAT IS
FOCUSED ON WOMEN'S RIGHTS ISSUE
- HAVING MAJORITY OF MEN THAT
NOT WOMEN- HAVE A- A COMMITTEE
THAT ON- BLACK- ENDED- SUCH AND
BLACK FOR THE MEDICAL AND HAVING
- WHITE WHEN THEY THE WHOLE
OTHER- PEOPLE WHO ARE NOT BLACK
BOYS AND MEN. NET COMMITTEE SODA
BARS ARE PERSPECTIVE THAT HAVING
A COMMITTEE LIKE THAT IS- MUST
HAVE A MAJORITY OF PEOPLE WITH
INTELLECTUAL AND DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES OR MENTAL HEALTH
DISABILITIES ON IT- DENTAL THAT
IS OUR POSITION THANK YOU CHAIR
MEMBERS AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR AND THE
SPONSOR ON- HOPEFULLY- RESULT IN
SOME OF OUR CONCERNS. THANK YOU
. MY WRITER WE HAVE NO WITNESS
IN OBJECTION. ED IN UPPER AS
REMOTE PLEASE ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO. EIGHT EIGHT TWO. M. MR
CHERNOBYL ELSE'S QUEUING UP AT
THIS TIME. GREAT NOW WILL BRING
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE ANY
QUESTIONS OR CONCERNS AS RELATES
TO AS THREE EIGHT EIGHT TWO.
SENATOR TOM WATER. OF THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN I JUST WANT TO
THINK- SENATOR EGGMAN FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD SHE
AND I HAD TALKED ABOUT IT
YESTERDAY- AND I. WOULD-
ACTUALLY LIKE TO BE- ADDED ON AS
A CO AUTHOR BECAUSE I THINK.
ELEVATING THE ISSUES OF THE ACT
I D. D. COMMUNITY- IS INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT. I ALSO WANT TO ECHO
SOME OF THE COMMON SHARED BY THE
ADVOCATE FROM DRC- YOU KNOW AND-MY HOPE IS THAT AS THIS BILL
CONTINUES TO MOVE THROUGH THE
PROCESS. THAT THE ROLE OF THE
COUNCIL IS NOT TO FOCUS
PRIMARILY ON TRAINING AND THE
REASON WHY I SAY THAT IS BECAUSE
THERE WAS AN INCIDENT THAT
HAPPENED LAST YEAR. IN L. A.
COUNTY WHERE A YOUNG MAN. WITH
SCOLIOSIS WHO IS AUTISTIC- AND
DEAF PARTIALLY- WAS ESSENTIALLY
SHOT BY A DEPUTY FROM THE
SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT THAT THE
DEPARTMENT HAD ALREADY GONE
THROUGH A SERIES OF TRAINING
PROGRAMS AND IN FACT DURING THE
COURSE OF THE INVESTIGATION IT
WAS REVEALED THAT I THINK WITHIN
A YEAR OF THAT HAPPENING ARE
PRIOR TO THAT HAPPENING. EVEN
THE DEPUTIES INVOLVED HAD GONE
THROUGH THE TRAINING PROCESS AND
HAD BEEN WORKING WITH DISABILITY
GROUPS AND SO IT SHOWS THAT THE
ISSUE ISN'T THE REMEDY IS AND
ALSO ALWAYS TRAINING. BUT IT IS
HOW LAW ENFORCEMENT SEE THE IDT
COMMUNITIES MAYBE HOW THEY ARE
WORKING MORE AGGRESSIVELY WITH
ADVOCATES FROM THAT PARTICULAR
SPACE- TO HELP THEM IDENTIFY-
BEHAVIORS OR TRAITS OR TRIGGERS
EXCEPT AROUND BECAUSE ULTIMATELY
AT THE END OF THE DAY YOU KNOW
WE'RE DEALING WITH A POPULATION
THAT MAY HAVE UNREGULATED-
BODIES AND IT CERTAINLY DOESN'T.
SUGGEST THAT AS A RESULT BAD
THINGS SHOULD HAPPEN TO THEM SO
MY HOPE IS THAT SOMEHOW DURING
THE COURSE OF THIS- PROCESS THAT
SOME OF THAT CAN BE INCLUDED AND
THEN- MAYBE ALSO. THE TO
CONSIDER FOR THAT COUNCIL
MEMBERSHIP YOU KNOW IF ADVOCATES
COULD ALSO INCLUDE THOSE WHO
HAVE REPRESENTED VICTIMS OR
SURVIVORS. OF PARTICULAR
INCIDENTS THAT COME FROM THE IDT
COMMUNITY BECAUSE I THINK THOSE
FOLKS ACTUALLY HAVE A BIRD'S-EYE
VIEW OF WHAT'S HAPPENING FROM
BOTH SIDES AND CAN MAYBE HELP IN
SOME OF THE DISCUSSIONS THAT
WE'RE TRYING TO- REVEAL FROM THE
COUNCIL SO THAT WE CAN SEE
BETTER OUTCOMES. BUT THANK YOU
FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD-
BECAUSE THIS IS AN ISSUE IN A
POPULATION THAT'S REALLY DEAR TO
ME. THANK YOU THANK YOU BUT SURE
CHOI BOOK. GOOD MORNING. FIRST
OF ALL THANK YEAR WINDOW TO ECHO
SOME OF THE CONCERT AT THE
COMMENTS MADE EARLIER BY MY
COLLEAGUE BUT I JUST WANNA THANK
YOU FOR THE FOR BRINGING THIS
BILL FORWARD I'M ALWAYS AN
ADVOCATE FOR. MORE BRITISH NO
TRAINING WHEN IT COMES TO OUR
LAW ENFORCEMENT I THINK THAT'S
ONE OF THE CONCERNS THAT I HAVE
HEARD. FROM MY LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT- COMMUNITIES IS THAT
WE SHOULD INVEST IN- ADDITIONAL
TRAINING WE CAN NEVER HAVE
ENOUGH TRAINING IN A WEEK WE CAN
SEE THAT IN MANY MANY FIELDS IN
EDUCATION- IN THE MEDICAL FIELD
THERE'S ALWAYS SOMETHING THAT WE
CAN ALWAYS LEARN AND PREPARE FOR
SO- THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
BRING THIS FOR THAN I. ALSO
WOULD LIKE TO BE ADDED AS A CO
AUTHOR ON THIS BILL THAT
POSSIBLE THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY. CENTER SKINNER.
AND I'D LIKE TO MOVE THE BILL AT
THE APPROPRIATE TIME OKAY IT'S
BEEN MOVED CENTER SKINNER THANK
YOU I'M CHAIR. THANK YOU-
CENTERING IN FOR BRING THIS
FORWARD I LIKE THE THERE'S A BIG
. I THINK OBVIOUSLY WE DO NEED
TO IMPROVE TRAINING BUT I THINK
S. B. DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA POINTED OUT WE ALSO
KNOW IN MY COLLEAGUES ARE FROM
LOS ANGELES POINTED OUT THAT
TRAINING WE KNOW THAT TRAINING
ALONE MAY NOT BE SUFFICIENT SO I
LIKE THE TICKET IN THE BILL OF
PROVIDING RECOMMENDATIONS FOR
IMPROVING OUTCOMES. AND WHAT.
WHAT I WAS GOING TO SUGGEST AND
COURSE NOT TO DO IT HERE BUT AND
I READ THE ANALYSIS THAT I DID
NOT READ THE ENTIRE BILL TAXI
MAY ALREADY SPECIFIED BUT THAT
YOU MIGHT WANT TO. ENHANCE THE
PARTS AROUND IMPROVING OUTCOMES
SO THAT IT DOESN'T ONLY
REFERENCE TRAINING BUT BLIGHTED
DITION ONLY WHAT- YOU KNOW WHAT
OTHER WHAT OTHER OPTIONS ARE
THERE FOR US RIGHT. NOW WE KNOW
THAT RIGHT NOW WE'RE WE MANY OF
OUR COMMUNITIES AND THE STATE'S
PILOTING TRYING DIFFERENT
APPROACHES WHERE WE WOULD SEND
SOMETHING OTHER THAN LAW
ENFORCEMENT BUT THAT'S NOT
STATEWIDE YET. AND WE DON'T EVEN
HAVE THE STAFFING CAPABILITIES
TO DO THAT STATEWIDE YET SO
UNTIL WE HAVE THAT COMPLETELY
RESOLVED THEN THIS IS A VERY
IMPORTANT STEP. BUT I WOULD I DO
VERY MUCH WITH WE HAVE A COUNCIL
LIKE THIS AND THEY'RE REVIEWING
DATA. THAT TO HAVE THAT YOU KNOW
STRENGTHENED OUR ABILITY FOR
THEM TO BRING US RECOMMENDATIONS
BECAUSE THEY'LL BE LOOK AT THEIR
RIGHT INTERACTING WITH POST
LOOKING AT DATA REALLY HELPING
US BECAUSE AS CITED. IN THE NOW
SINCE WE KNOW. THAT THE END
YOURS AUTHOR STATEMENT ALSO THAT
WE KNOW THAT PEOPLE WITH MENTAL
AND PHYSICAL DISABILITIES ARE
MORE LIKELY TO UNFORTUNATELY-
EXPERIENCE- IF VIOLENCE OR EVEN
DEATH. WHEN THEY INTERACT WITH
LAW ENFORCEMENT. BUT WE ALSO
THIS OCCURS. IN OUR JAILS IN OUR
CUSTODIAL SETTINGS WHEN WE LOOK
AT WHO DIES IN JAIL CUSTODY OR
EVEN IN PRISON CUSTODY OFTEN.
IT'S A VERY- YOU KNOW IT'S NOT.
UNCOMMON FOR THAT PERSON TO
HAVE. THE THESE KIND OF
DISABILITIES THAT ARE EITHER
INTERPRETED BY. YOU KNOW THERE
CONSTRUED OFFICER IS BEING JUST
LIKE- DEFIANT BEHAVIOR SOMETHING
VERSUS THE ACTUAL WEATHER IF THE
PERSON'S ARTISTIC OR WHO KNOWS
ON WHAT WHAT THEY'RE DIFFERENT
DISABILITY IS THAT IT IS JUST
THEIR BEHAVIOR THERE IS NOT
ANYTHING THEY CAN CONTROL ABOUT
THAT. AND SO- WE OBVIOUSLY WE
DON'T WANT PEOPLE PEOPLE SHOULD
NOT HAVE TO BE IN THAT SITUATION
DATE IF YOU IF YOU HAVE THAT
PARTICULAR KIND OF DISABILITY
I'M SORRY IT'S NOT SOMETHING
THAT. YOU HAVE YOU HAVE THE E.
IN ORDER TO JUST VOTE CHANGE HER
BEHAVIOR ENACT LIKE SOMEONE ELSE
EXPECTS YOU TO ACT. SO I'M GLAD
THAT IT- THAT THE BILL HAS MORE
THAN JUST THE TRAINING AND I
HOPE THAT THAT ASPECT OF IT CAN
BE ENHANCED AS IT MOVES THROUGH
THE PROCESS. THANK YOU. THANK
THANK YOU ANY OTHER IS TO COME
TO QUESTIONS OF CENTER TO I WANT
TO THANK YOU FOR THIS COMMON
SENSE MEASURE AND- APPRECIATE.
THE THOUGHTFULNESS HERE BECAUSE
IT'S- LEGISLATION WHICH TRULY
NEEDED OUR DISABILITY COMMUNITY
NOT ONLY NEEDS TO BE RESPECTED
BUT PROTECTED AS WELL SO ON THAT
NOTE- IF YOU LIKE TO CLOSE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AND THANK YOU ALL
FOR YOUR YOUR THOUGHTFUL
COMMENTS YEAH AND I THINK THIS
IS A POPULATION THAT WE ALL KNOW
NEEDS OFTEN HAS MORE THAN ONE
ISSUE GOING ON AND YOU HEARD
FROM A PARENT. YOU KNOW WE HAVE
THE POPULATION ALSO THE PARENTS
WHO THE LAST THING THEY WANT TO
HAVE TO DO IS CALL NINE ONE ONE-
WHEN THEY WHEN THEY KNOW THEIR
CHILD IS IT EVEN MORE AT RISK
JUST DUE TO HOW THEY HOW THEY
PRESENT THEMSELVES OFTENTIMES
AND THEIR INABILITY TO FOLLOW- A
DIRECTION THAT SOMEONE MIGHT
MEDAVOY'S EXPECTS ME TO FOLLOW
SO- THANK YOU FOR THE COMMENTS
AND WE WILL CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH DISABILITY RIGHTS BUT YES
THIS IS NOT JUST ABOUT TRAINING
IT'S ABOUT GATHERING THE DATA.
WITH REPRESENTATION BILL
ACTUALLY LOOK AT IT AND I THINK
THAT CENTER SCANNERS AND
ABOUT TRAINING BUT LOOKING AT AT
THE TRAINING IS LOOKING AT THE
OUTCOMES THE INTERVENTIONS AND
ALSO I THINK THE CONTEXT IN
WHICH THOSE. RIGHT SOMETHING
BAD. LOOK WHAT WERE DO THEY WHAT
ELSE TODAY TO OFFER DID THEY- A
MENTAL HEALTH. PERSON O OUT
WITH THEM OR DID THEY HAVE TO
SET UP. TO WITHIN ALSO I THINK
BE INSTRUCTIVE TO WHAT PEOPLE
NEED TO DEVELOP ON THE GROUND.
SO THAT EITHER LAW ENFORCEMENT
DOESN'T HAVE TO GO OUT OR
THEY'RE GOING OUT. IN SOME KIND
OF OTHER COMMUNITY SO WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK ON THIS I THANK
YOU FOR YOUR- SUPPORT I THINK
IT'S INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT. AND A
PEACE OF MIND FOR- FOR BOTH
PEOPLE SUFFERING. FROM IDENTITY
ISSUES AND ALSO- THEIR FAMILIES
AND LAW ENFORCEMENT SO WITH THAT
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
VOTE. THANK YOU WE HAVE A MOTION
BY SENATOR COM LONGER WE HAVE A
TO PASS AS AMENDED TO THIS
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
ACCOUNTS PLEASE CALL. THE WORLD
ON S. B. EIGHT EIGHT TWO SB
EIGHT EIGHT TO DO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
BRADFORD. EFFORT I'D SHOW BOTH
HI TROUBLE GUY COME LONGER. AND
LONGER AYE SKINNER. SKINNER AYE
WINNER. WINNER I'VE FIVE ZERO.
THE MEASURE HAS FIVE VOTES YOU
SEXUAL SUCCESSFULLY OF COMMITTEE
CONGRATULATIONS THANK YOU. NEXT
UP WE HAVE SENATOR. LEYVA. AND
SHE'LL BE PRESENTING. S. B. NINE
ONE. ALL GUYS WE ARE ONE ITEM ON
WE HAVE AS- EIGHT SEVEN TWO- WE
CALL THE ROLL ON OUR CONCERN
NINE. SB EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN
CONSENT CALENDAR BRADFORD
BRADFORD AYE CHOI BOGUE. HI
TROUBLE GUY CAMARGO KAMAGRA AYE
SKINNER SKINNER I WINNER WINNER
I'VE FIVE ZERO THAT ITEM
RECEIVED FIVE VOTES TO CONCERNED
ITEMS OUT. NEXT UP IS SENATOR
LEVEL WOULD SB NINE ONE SIX
SERVER LIFE GOOD MORNING MISTER
CHAIR GOOD MORNING MEMBERS IT'S
A PLEASURE TO BE HERE TODAY
ESPECIALLY SINCE THIS IS THE
LAST HEARING IN FORTY TWO OH
THREE EFFORT SO WE'RE HERE-
CREATING A LITTLE HISTORY.
SENATE BILL NINE SIXTEEN AIMS TO
EMPOWER SURVIVORS OFSEXUAL
ASSAULT ACROSS CALIFORNIA SB
NINE SIXTEEN UPDATES CURRENT LAW
TO REQUIRE THAT THE INFORMATION
GIVEN TO A SURVIVOR OF SEXUAL
ASSAULT INCLUDES A STATEMENT
THAT THEY CANNOT BE FOUND IN
CONTEMPT FOR NOT TESTIFYING AS
WELL AS TO MAKE IT A RIGHT FOR A
SURVIVOR TO REQUEST SPECIFIC
pREGARDING ANY DNA SAMPLES THAT
WERE TAKEN THIS IMPORTANT
MEASURE WILL HELP EMPOWER SEXUAL
ASSAULT SURVIVORS ACROSS OUR
STATE AND HELP THEM CONTINUE IN
THEIR HEALING PROCESS WITH ME
TODAY VIRTUALLY IS DA O'MALLEY-
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU- WE
HAVE NANCY O'MALLEY'S D. A.
ALAMEDA COUNTY AS YOUR PRIMARY
WITNESS IN SUPPORT. D. A. MALING
WHEN YOU'RE READY- YOU MAY BEGIN
YOUR TESTIMONY OF FOUR MINUTES.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. MY
NAME IS NANCY O'MALLEY'S HE SAID
IN IN ADDITION IN ADDITION TO
BEING THE DISTRICT ATTORNEY I'VE
BEEN AN ADVOCATE FOR VICTIMS OF
SEXUAL ASSAULT FOR MORE THAN
FORTY YEARS I BEGAN AS A RAPE
CRISIS VOLUNTEER. IN THE
NINETEEN SEVENTIES AND I HAVE
SEEN THE INCREDIBLE PROGRESS
YOUR LEGISLATURE HAS MADE AND
PROTECTING AND ENSURING THE
RIGHTS OF SEXUAL ASSAULT
SURVIVORS. FOR THE LAST SEVERAL
YEARS- LEGISLATURES BEEN
ENACTING LAWS THAT SPECIFICALLY
ENHANCE THE RIGHTS AND
PROTECTIONS OF INDIVIDUALS WHO
HAVE BEEN SEXUALLY ASSAULTED. IF
THEY CAN'T TO THE ENACTMENT OF
THESE LAWS HAS BEEN ESSENTIALLY
GIVING POWER BACK TO THE VICTIM
SURVIVOR. WHEN SOMEONE IS
SEXUALLY ASSAULTED FOR THAT
PERIOD OF TIME ALL POWER CHOICE
AND DECISION OR TAKING AWAY
TAKEN AWAY. GIVING BACK POWER
COMES IN THE FORM OF DECISION
MAKING I BEING KEPT INFORMED OF
ANY PROGRESS OR ACTION TAKEN IN
THE CASE. ENSURING RESPECT AND
CARE FROM THE SYSTEMS IN PLACE
TO SUPPORT HER OR HIM. AND THIS
HAS BEEN PARTICULARLY TRUE IN
THE AREA OF TESTING SEXUAL
ASSAULT FORENSIC EVIDENCE KIT.
UNDER THE LEADERSHIP OF NOW
SENATOR AND THEN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SKINNER. AND MORE RECENTLY UNDER
THE LEADERSHIP OF SENATOR LEYVA.
THE LAW NOW REQUIRES LAW
ENFORCEMENT TO SAID THAT SEXUAL
ASSAULT KITS FOR TESTING. WITHIN
STRICT TIME FRAMES. DRIVING
THOSE TWO LAWS WAS THE FACT THAT
LAW ENFORCEMENT WAS SIMPLY NOT
SENDING FORENSIC EVIDENCE KITS
TO CRIME LAB FOR TESTING. IN
SPITE OF THE FACT THAT THE
VICTIM SURVIVOR HAD CONSENTED TO
HAVE THE KIDS. DONE AND AT FULL
SPEED PATIENTS THAT SOMETHING
WOULD BE DONE WITH THAT CAT.
VICTIM SURVIVORS NEVER EVEN KNEW
THOUGH LAW ENFORCEMENT IS
REQUIRED- WHAT'S REQUIRED BY LAW
TO NOTIFY VICTIMS SURVIVOR. THAT
THE KID WAS NOT BEING TESTED
THAT'S DID NOT HAVE FOR FIVE TOO
MANY. EVERYTHING TO YOUR IN
RESPONSE RELIGIOUS PASS LAWS THE
HOLD MOM ACCOUNT. BY DIRECTING
THAT OF JUSTICE TO CREATE SAFE
HE SEPARATE DATABASE THAT
REQUIRES LAW ENFORCEMENT TO
ENTER DATA REGARDING THE
PROGRESS OF THE INDIVIDUAL KIDS.
THIS BILL SB NINE SIXTEEN
REITERATES THAT SEXUAL ASSAULT
VICTIM SURVIVOR CAN ACCESS HIS
OR HER OWN FILING SAFETY. SHE HE
CAN ENSURE THAT LAW ENFORCEMENT
IS TAKING ALL LEGAL STEPS I HAD
TO GET TESTED. TASTY DATABASE
DOES NOT CONTAIN MEDICAL
INFORMATION IT CONTAINS
DOCUMENTATION THAT THE KID WAS
BOOKED INTO AN EVIDENCE ROOM AT
THE POLICE DEPARTMENT THAT IT
HAS BEEN SUBMITTED FOR TESTING
WITHIN THE TIME FRAMES AND THAT
BUT AND THE PROGRESS FOLLOWING
SUBMISSION. IN ADDITION FOR MORE
THAN FORTY YEARS CALIFORNIA LAW
HAS STATED THAT A VICTIM
SURVIVORS SEXUAL ASSAULT CANNOT
BE HELD IN CONTEMPT OF THE COURT
INCLUDING IMPRISONMENT OR
CONFINEMENT. FOR REFUSING TO
TESTIFY ABOUT THE SEXUAL ASSAULT
CRIME IT AGAINST HER OR HIM.
THIS BILL REQUIRES TO ADD A
STATEMENT OF THAT LOBBY INCLUDED
IN THE CARD PROVIDED TO THE
VICTIM SURVIVOR THAT OUTLINES
THE RIGHTS AND PROTECTIONS SHE
OR HE HAS UNDER CALIFORNIA LAW.
HOW TO SAY THAT MY OFFICE HAS
BEEN IN THE FOREFRONT OF
ADDRESSING THE BACKLOG OF
UNTESTED KITS. IN CALIFORNIA
ACROSS THE UNITED STATES AND IN
EXPANDING PROTECTIONS AND
RESPECT FOR INDIVIDUALS HAVE
BEEN SEXUALLY ASSAULTED. I THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME. I URGE AN AYE
VOTE THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK
YOU MICHELLE WILL MOVE TO THE
HEARING FORTY TWO OH THREE DO WE
HAVE WITNESSES WISHING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. OF SB NINE
ONE SIX YES THANK YOU CHAIR
MEMBERS KIM STONE OF STONE
ADVOCACY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA DISTRICT ATTORNEYS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU NEXT WITNESS. TO TURN
MEMBERS ALEX TOWARDS THE
STRATEGIES THREE SIXTY ON BEHALF
OF LEAD TO HEALTH WE LIKE TO
THINK DISTRICT ATTORNEY O'MALLEY
FOR HER GREAT COMMENTS IN THE
SENATOR FOR WORKING ON THIS. NOT
ONLY THIS MEASURE BUT MEASURES
AFTER AS WELL THANK YOU SO MUCH
THANK YOU ANY ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF US THREE
NINE ONE SIX YEAR AND FORTY TWO
OR THREE. TURNING TO NONE NOW
MODERATE. TO THE FOR LUNCH DO WE
HAVE ANYONE WISHING TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT. OF S. B. NINE ONE
SIX. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR- TO
EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR SB NINE ONE
SIX PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME. AND NOBODY IS QUEUING
UP MISTER CHAIR. OKAY NOW WILL
MOVE TO OPPOSITION WE HAVE NO
LEAD OPPOSITION LISTEN ON THIS
MEASURE IS OR ANYONE HERE IN A
ROOM FORTY TWO- THREE WISHING TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION OF US
THREE NINE ONE SIX. HEARING TÍNH
NONE MODERATOR NOW WILL GO TO
THE PHONE MUCH. THANK YOU TO OUR
EXPRESS OPPOSITION FOR SB NINE
ONE SIX PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT THIS TIME.
NO PARTICIPANTS ARE QUEUING UP.
OKAY CENTER LIVE HE DONE A GREAT
JOB OF SCARING OFF ALL
OPPOSITION- DO WE CAN- WILL NOW
MOVE BACK TO COMMISSIONERS
CANNOT. THANK YOU DEAR THANK YOU
CENTER LEYVA FOR BRING THE BILL-
WELL IT'S CLEAR IN THE ANALYSIS
THAT WE'VEALREADY GIVEN THE
PERSON WHO IS REPORTED TO SEXUAL
ASSAULT. THE ABILITY TO YOU KNOW
ASK FOR THIS INFORMATION IT'S
NOT A HEROES HAS SO MANY THINGS
WE DO THE PERSON THE SEXUAL
ASSAULT SURVIVOR DOESN'T ALWAYS
KNOW AND DOESN'T ALWAYS KNOW WHO
TO CONTACT IN SO THIS IS A
NEEDED NOW. THE QUESTION I HAVE.
AND IT HAD- THIS BILL IS NARROW
IN THAT IT JUST BECAUSE PROVIDES
THIS CARD BUT THE QUESTION I
HAVE FOR THE AUTHOR IN PERHAPS
FOR YOUR LEAD WITNESS IT IS.
WHETHER IN IN MAYBE HAS TO BE
DONE IN ANOTHER BILL BUT WHETHER
WE NEED. TO ADD A FURTHER
PROTECTION TO OUR SEXUAL ASSAULT
SURVIVORS. BECAUSE IT IS COME
OUT NOW THAT WE HAVE HAD AT
LEAST ONE- PROSECUTOR'S OFFICE
NOT PROSECUTOR WAS PUT AT LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCY. THAT TOOK
THE DNA OF A SEXUAL ASSAULT
SURVIVORS IN OTHER WORDS TOOK
TOOK THE EVIDENCE FROM THE RAPE
KIT. AND PLACES WHERE I WOULD
NEVER SAY THAT BECAUSE I HATE
THAT TERM BUT WHATEVER TOOK THAT
EVIDENCE. ARENDT PUT IT THROUGH
THE SAME DATABASE TO SEE WHETHER
THAT PERSON HAD. IT WAS
ASSOCIATED WITH THE CRIME AND OF
COURSE RIGHT NOW WE KNOW THAT.
THE REPORTING RATES FOR SEXUAL
IF YOU WERE SEXUALLY ASSAULTED.
THE VERY IDEA THE VERY ACT OF
GOING TO LAW ENFORCEMENT IS
ALREADY SUCH A LOW PERCENT. THAT
WE DO NOT WANT TO DO ANYTHING
THAT THAT MINIMIZES OR LESSONS
OR HAS THE CHILLING EFFECT ON
PEOPLE TO REPORT THEIR ASSAULT.
AND SO NOW WE WITH THIS WE'RE
TRYING TO ASSIST THOSE
SURVIVORS. BUT DO WE NEED ALSO
TO ENSURE THAT THERE THE
EVIDENCE THAT THEY'VE SUBMITTED
WILL THEN NOT BE USED AGAINST
THEM. SO I'M JUST WONDERING IF
EITHER THE AUTHOR OR THE- EARLY
PROPONENT WANTS TO ADDRESS THAT
THANK YOU CENTERS CAN I AM WELL
AWARE OF THE CASE IN WHICH
YOU'RE TALKING BUT I DO THINK
THAT DETAIL MALLEY WOULD BE
BETTER FIRST AND PROBABLY ANSWER
YOUR QUESTION BETTER. DO MALLEY
ARE YOU STILL THERE. I AM YES
THANK YOU THANK YOU. D. SAID THE
OCCURRENCE OF WHAT HAPPENED IN
SAN FRANCISCO WITH THEIR CRIME
LAB IS. OUTRAGEOUS AND I BELIEVE
IT'S AN ANOMALY TO HOW. THE
CRIME LABS IN CALIFORNIA HAVE.
BEEN PROCESSING. IT IT'S VERY
CLEAR AND I'VE CONFIRM THIS WITH
SEVERAL OF THEM AND A MAJORITY
OF THE- DNA. ANALYSIS IS BEING
DONE BY OUR CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE. THERE THE
CRIME LAB FOR FORTY EIGHT OF THE
COUNTIES- INTO THEIR VERY FEW
CAPS THAT ARE. I THINK IN THEIR
OWN COUNTY IN MY COUNTY SO THE-
B. I DON'T KNOW WHAT THE
LANGUAGE WOULD ACTUALLY LOOK
LIKE BECAUSE- IT'S AN ANOMALY
THAT HAPPENED AND OTHER CRIME
LABS ARE NOT KEEPING THE
SEPARATE DATABASES THAT CONTAIN
THE VICTIM SURVIVORS DNA OR ANY
OTHER. BIOLOGICAL REFERENCE OF
THE VICTIM. AND SO I YOU KNOW
AGAIN I THINK THAT IT'S EVEN
TAKE TO WHAT HAPPENED IN SAN
FRANCISCO THEY HAVE DECLARED
THAT THEY ARE CORRECTING
WHATEVER THE- SITUATIONS THAT
THEY CREATED- AND- IF THERE IS
SOME DISCUSSION POINT ABOUT
TRYING TO COME UP WITH FASHION
SOME LANGUAGE I'M VERY HAPPY TO
BE INVOLVED WITH THAT. WELL IN
PERHAPS IT IS ONE OF THOSE
THINGS WE HAVE WE WOULD HAVE TO
DO SEPARATELY BUT WHILE IT MAY
BE UNIQUE AND AN ANOMALY IT
HAPPENED. IT WAS HIGH PROFILED
AND SO IT. IT I CAN'T HELP BUT
KNOW THAT IT'S GOING TO HAVE A
FURTHER CHILLING EFFECT. ON
PEOPLE WHO ARE SEXUALLY
ASSAULTED FROM REPORTING. THEIR
ASSAULT I AM VERY UNFORTUNATELY
WE KNOW. THAT- SEVEN FOLDABLE
PEOPLE BACK WHETHER THEY'RE ON
HOW STE. WHETHER ANY NINE HAVE
ADDICTS UNITS ARE MORE. LIKELY
TO WIN MAYBE NOT MORE LIKELY BUT
THEY ARE PRONE TO BEING SEXUALLY
ASSAULTED BECAUSE THEY ARE THEY
ARE. MORE VULNERABLE THEY HAVE
LESS- JUST LESS SAFEGUARDS AND
PROTECTIONS WHETHER BECAUSE THEY
LIVE ON THE STREET OR BECAUSE
THEY ARE IN OTHER CIRCUMSTANCES.
AND YET THERE ARE SALTY'S
JUSTICE CRIMINALS ANYBODY.
ELSE'S AND WE NEED EVERYBODY TO
REPORT. SO IN WE MAY NEED FIX
THAT WHILE ICE THIS BILL AS
IMPORTANT TO HELP SUPPORT. OUR
SURVIVORS OF SEXUAL ASSAULT AND
TO GIVE THEM YOU KNOW FURTHER
INTO AN- MMHM AGENCY TO ACT ON
THEIR BEHALF I ALSO WANT TO
ENSURE THAT WE'RE NOT. IN OTHER
WAYS CREATING A CHILLING EFFECT
SO- BUT I WOULD MOVE THE BILL.
THANK YOU SURE WINNER. THANK YOU
AND JUST TO ALERT EVERYONE THAT
WILL BE HERE IN THIS COMMITTEE
WE- THAT'LL EXISTS- IT'S S. B.
TWELVE TWENTY EIGHT WHICH I
INTRODUCED A FEW WEEKS AGO TO
BAN ON THE PRACTICE OF MISUSING-
RAPE KIT ANOTHER VICTIM DNA TO
THE AND PROSECUTE. THAT PICKED
UP THE VICTIM IN THE FUTURE IS
TO MISS USE THAT DENIES WERE
CATEGORICALLY BANNING THAT
PRACTICE- WHAT HAPPENED WITH US
OF PITTI WAS JUST JUST SHOCKING-
MIND BLOWING THAT THAT WOULD
HAPPEN AND I KNOW EVEN THOUGH
CHIEF SCOTT AND SAN FRANCISCO
HAS INDICATED THAT HE DOES NOT
CONDONE THAT AND TO GET A CHANGE
OF POLICIES AND EVEN THOUGH
THERE'S A LOCAL AND NOW
INTRODUCED OF THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS AND SAN FRANCISCO TO
BAN THE PRACTICE- BUT WE NEED TO
SHUT IT DOWN STATEWIDE TO MAKE
SURE IT NEVER HAPPENS AGAIN.
THANKS IN THE VERY VERY CLEAR
AND POWERFUL POWERFUL MESSAGE TO
VICTIMS THAT WE KNOW IT IS SO
DRAMATIC TO COME FORWARD TO
REPORT TO REPORT SEXUAL ASSAULT
AND THAT'S WHY SO FEW PEOPLE DO
IT AND IT IS EVEN MORE- DRAMATIC
TO GO TO THE- IT MEET. AFTER YOU
HAVE BEEN SEXUALLY ASSAULTED
THREE TIMES BEEN SO BADLY
TRAUMATIZED. AND NOW YOU HAVE TO
YOU CAN'T WAIT A WEEK. YOU GOT
TO GO IMMEDIATELY TO THE
HOSPITAL TO HAVE AN INVASIVE.
EXAM DONE IT'S TOUGH FOR A RATE
CUT. AND THE LAST THING WE NEED
TO DO IS SEND A MESSAGE WELL
THAT MAYBE IS GOING TO BE USED
AGAINST YOU IN THE FUTURE WE
NEED SOME A CLEAR MESSAGE THAT
WILL NOT BE USED AGAINST YOU IN
THAT WE SUPPORT YOU. SO THAT'S
WHY WE'VE INTRODUCED US BE TALL
TWENTY. THANK YOU. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSS S. US SOONER TROUBLE-
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THE BILL
FORWARD SENATOR LEYVA AYE AND
ACTUALLY I WOULD LIKE TO BE
ADDED AS A CO AUTHOR OF
POSSIBLE. WOULD BE HAPPY TO HAVE
YOU. Q. ANY FURTHER. COME TO
TESTIMONY BY COLLEAGUES HERE
NINETEEN ONLY A MOTION SIR.
LEVEL CHUCK CLOSE THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR I JUST WANT TO
REITERATE WHAT CENTER SKINNER
SAID ABOUT INFORMATION- THE
OTHER TOPIC WE GOT ONTO I'M
EXCITED ABOUT. TWELVE TWENTY
EIGHT AND I'M SURE WE'LL HAVE A
FULL ROBUST DISCUSSION ABOUT
THAT BUT BACK TO NINE SIXTEEN.
IT IS ABOUT EMPOWERING VICTIMS
BY MAKING SURE THAT THEY HAVE
THE INFORMATION. A LOT OF TIMES
WE PASS LAWS HERE IN THIS
BUILDING. AND WE DON'T ALWAYS
GET THAT INFORMATION OUT BUT
MAKING SURE THAT THIS CARD IS
UPDATED. SO THAT THE SURVIVORS
KNOW EXACTLY WHAT THEIR RIGHTS
ARE IS EXTREMELY IMPORTANT SO
MEMBERS I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AND I'VE- THANK YOU. COUNSEL
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON SB NINE
ONE SIX. IT'S TO PASS- TO
OPERATIONS SB NINE ONE SIX TO
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS BRADFORD.
BRADFORD SHOW BOTH THE TROUBLE
GUY COM LONGER SKINNER. SKINNER
AYE WINNER WINNER I HOLD THE
ROLE FOR. THAT MEASURE HAS FOUR
VOTES WILL LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS THANK YOU
CONGRADULATIONS NEXT. NEXT UP WE
HAVE SENATOR JONES WOULD S. B.
ONE ZERO ZERO SIX ONE THOUSAND
SIX. MEMBERS THE BILL WHAT DOES
YOUR SIX CREATES A GRANT PROGRAM
FOR LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES TO FUND HOMELESS
OUTREACH TEAMS ALSO KNOWN AS HOT
TEAMS ARE WRAPAROUND SERVICE
TEAMS I THINK YOUR- NOW IS THIS
CAMINO SAYS MULTI MULTI
DISCIPLINARY TEAMS. UNDER THE
BILL- THESE TEAMS MUST BE
COMPRISED OF AT A MINIMUM I
HEALTH MENTAL HEALTH
PROFESSIONAL A MEDICAL SERVICES
PROFESSIONALLY COUNTY WELFARE
REPRESENTATIVE AND A LOT OF
FORCE MET REPRESENTATIVE. THE
BILL ALSO ALLOWS NONPROFITS AND
GRADUATE STUDENTS TO PARTICIPATE
IN THE TEAMS. THE TEAMS GO OUT
OF THE FIELD IN THE MIDDLE YOU
CUT CONNECT HOMELESS INDIVIDUALS
TO HOUSING AND SUPPORTIVE
SERVICES. SEVERAL COUNTIES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE ALREADY USE
HOMELESS OUTREACH TEAMS AND THEY
ARE PROVEN TO BE EXTREMELY
EFFECTIVE. HOWEVER THEIR HIGH
COSTS POSE A BARRIER FOR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO IMPLEMENT THEM.
TO FUNDING THIS GRANT PROGRAM OF
S. B. ONE ZERO ZERO SIX I HAVE
SUBMITTED A BUDGET REQUEST FOR
ONE HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS. CALIFORNIA'S HOMELESS
CRISIS CONTINUES TO WORSEN AND
WE MUST PURSUE EFFECTIVE
STRATEGIES TO HELP RELIEVE IT.
S. B. ONE ZERO ZERO SIX IS ONE
STEP THEY CAN BE TAKEN
IMMEDIATELY TO CONNECT HOMELESS
INDIVIDUALS WITH SERVICES. AND
I. RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT AND I VOTE. THANK YOU
YOU HAVE TWO PRIMARY WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT. OF RANDY PERRY AND
YOU HAVE RUNNING SHERMAN THEY'LL
BE A FORTY TWO MINUTES EACH.
MISTER PERRY'S ONLINE HE MAY
BEGIN TESTIMONY. MODERATOR TWO
WE HAVE TWO PRIMARY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT. AIRLINE SHOULD BE OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MEMBERS BEHIND
SHERMAN- ALTHOUGH I HAVE ALWAYS
WISHED TO PERRY- WITH THE
RIVERSIDE CHURCH THE- WERE
PLEASE SUPPORT IT AS. TEN TWENTY
TEN OH SIX. A MEASURE THAT WILL
GRANT FUNDS LOOK LONG AGENCIES
TO DALLAS NOT THE SERVICES.
PROVIDED TO OUR HOME BOB. IN AN
EFFORT TO IMPROVE THEIR SAFETY.
IN THE PUBLIC. S. B. CHANNEL SIX
THE DEPARTMENT JUSTICE WITH.
WOOD MISTER A COMPETITIVE FROM
BASED ON FUNDING BY LIKE. TO
ENABLE LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT. TO
ESTABLISH OUR- THE HOME WITHOUT
REACH. SOME POINTED OUT SAME
WILL INCLUDE PROFESSIONAL MENTAL
HEALTH AND MEDICAL TO PER. AS
WELL AS- OF THE CAN WELFARE.
YEAH FORCED OFF. INTO A FENCE
NEEDS OF HOMELESS. ALMOST AND
THEN BE TO DETERMINE THE BUS
OPTIONS TO THEM WITH THEIR HOW
MEDICAL HEALTH. TREATMENT
INTERESTS MEET. RIVERSIDE SHARES
IT. ITS OWN OF THE HOME CROWD
REACHED AS PART OF THIS EFFORT
SINCE POSTING AND THEM AVOID
REENTERING THE CRIMINAL SYSTEM
FORTUNE INADEQUATE FOR IS GOING
OUR- IS. OR REGION. WITH DEEP
PROFESSIONAL AGAIN SB HELLO. SIX
THE GENERALLY ACCEPTED THESE RAP
SIR TEAM CAN BE EXTREMELY
EFFECTIVE IN HELPING HOMELESS
BUT MANY COUNTIES INCLUDE OUR
OWN THE WILL CONFIRM. THE
SPECIFIC THING OF CHEAPER PROVEN
RESULTS BECAUSE THEY LACK THE US
TO HIRE. THE VERY. NEEDED TO
FILL THESE COUPLE THINGS. SB TWO
OF SIX PROVIDE GRANTS FOR. TO
LOOK ONE FOR AGENCIES AND WE YOU
SOME OF OUR TEAM. COORDINATE
HOUSE CONCERN. FROM INDIVIDUALS.
PLEASE SB TAYLOR SIX
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST LINE VOTE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NOT TO
ADDRESS. MISTER PERRY HOLDEN
HEARING THEM BUT PLEASE GO AHEAD
. MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS. WE
HOUSEHOLDS KORAK ALTHOUGH WE'RE
NOT THE SPONSORS OF THE BILL WE
HAVE BEEN TRYING FOR FOUR YEARS
TO GET FUNDING AND- VARIOUS
PROJECTS FOR LOCAL HOMELESS
OUTREACH TEAMS. LIKE THE
PREVIOUS. SPEAKER SAID THAT
THERE ARE PROGRAMS WERE AND AN
OFFICER WILL ACTUALLY BE TRAINED
IN ADDITION TO THEIR CURRENT
TRAINING THAT THEY RECEIVE- ON
HOMELESSNESS AND THE- ISSUES
SURROUNDING HOMELESSNESS. MENTAL
HEALTH OR DRUG AND ALCOHOL ABUSE
AND THEN THAT THOSE OFFICERS FOR
EXAMPLE ONCE AGAIN- OF STAIRS
SIX OFFICERS WITH THAT
ADDITIONALLY TRYING TO WORK FIVE
EIGHT HOUR SHIFTS WITH SOCIAL
SERVICES BACK BIRDS ON
HOMELESSNESS AND THEY WILL BE
CALLED OUT. THERE ARE THESE
TYPES OF CALLS AND THAT TEAM
WILL RESPOND THE OFFICER GOES IN
SEARCH- JERRY MAKE SURE
EVERYTHING'S OKAY AND THEN
BACKED OUT OF THE SITUATION AND
LET'S BE BACK SPORTS AND THAT
PARTICULAR ISSUE ARE GOING IN
AND THEN TRY TO GET HELP FROM
THE PERSON THAT THEY'RE
RESPONDING TO THE WORK BUT IT'S
A FUNDING ISSUE THE PROGRAMS
WE'VE SEEN ALL. ARE SHOULD BE
FOR OUR LOCAL INITIATIVE TRYING
TO PIECE TOGETHER FOR EXAMPLE
ANAHEIM HAS A VERY GOOD PROGRAM-
THEY'VE WORKED WITH THE COUNTY
BOARD WHO GAVE THEM TO YOU KNOW
HEALTH EXPERTS ON THEIR PROGRAM-
AND THEY RESPOND NOT ONLY TO
HOMELESSNESS BUT ALSO THE MENTAL
HEALTH ISSUES AND LIKE I SAID A
DRUG OR ALCOHOL ABUSE ISSUES
WHEN THEY TRY TO GET ON THE
SERVICES THEY WORK. PROGRAM
YOU'RE WORKING MANY CITIES ARE
TRYING IT NOW BUT THE FUNDING IS
THE ISSUE SO WE'RE HOPING THAT
IN THE FUTURE THIS WILL BE THE
FUTURE OF LAW ENFORCEMENT WHERE
OFFICERS WILL GO INTO SECURING
THE AREA BUT AND THEN STEP BACK
AND LET THE PEOPLE WHO ARE
EXPERTS HOW DOES. THAT THEY'RE
RESPONDING TO THANK YOU. OKAY
NOW WE'RE GONNA GO TO ARE IN
PERSON TO HAVE ANY HERE TO
THREE. PLEASE HOW RIGHT THERE
WOULD BE GREAT THANK YOU- AND
ALL RIGHT. OKAY NOW WE'RE GONNA
HEAD OVER TO THE PHONES-
MODERATOR DO WE HAVE ANYBODY
ONLINE. THANK YOU LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU'D LIKE TO
TESTIFY- AT FOR SB. NINE PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT
THIS TIME ONE FILED BY ZERO TO
TESTIFY. OR OR I JUST WANT TO
CLARIFY THAT WE ARE CURRENTLY
HEARING. WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
OF THIS BILL SB. ONE ZERO ZERO
SIX. AND AS A FINAL REMINDER TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT FOR SB ONE
ZERO ZERO SIX PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO. I'M SURE NOBODY IS KILLING
UP. IN SUPPORT OF OUR HEAD OVER
TO WITNESSES IN SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION OF SORRY. YES HI- IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO ONE FILED BY
ZERO TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION.
TO ONE ZERO ZERO SIX. I
APOLOGIZE MODERATOR AB MARINE
TRANSITION HERE SO GIVE ME ONE
SECOND WE ARE CURRENTLY GOING TO
HEAD OFF WITH THEIR LEAD
OPPOSITION IN PERSON HERE IN
ROOM FORTY TWO OR THREE. WE HAVE
DONE A CAT. SORRY RIGHT OUR MAIL
I'M FROM THE STATE POLICY AT
THERE IS THIS STATE POLICY
DIRECTOR AT SAN FRANCISCO PUBLIC
AND SEPARATE AT SAN FRANCISCO
PUBLIC DEFENDER. YES PLEASE
MA'AM THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING ED
SHEERAN MEMBERS DAN AYKROYD
ARMILLA BEHALF OF THE SAN
FRANCISCO PUBLIC DEFENDER IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL- WELL WE
APPRECIATE THIS STATEWIDE
CONCERN REGARDING HOMELESSNESS
AND THE URGENT NEED FOR
SOLUTIONS WE DO NOT BELIEVE THE
SOLUTION STARTS WITH INCREASED
LAW ENFORCEMENT. OR COMPONENT OF
OUR CULTURAL RECKONING BUT THE
ROLE POLICING PLAYS IN OUR
SOCIETY OVER THE LAST FEW YEARS
HAS BEEN OUR OVER RELIANCE ON
OFFICERS TO RESPOND TO
EMERGENCIES THAT FREQUENTLY DO
NOT REQUIRE LAW ENFORCEMENT. BUT
RATHER CRISIS RESPONSE MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES AND CARE. THESE
RESPONSES REQUIRED DIFFERENT
KIND OF TRAINING AND EXPERTISE
NOT POLICE. I WOULD ALSO NOTE
THAT ANY PROPOSAL TO CREATE MORE
RESPONSIBILITIES FOR POLICE
SHOULD BE RECONSIDERED GIVEN THE
RECENTLY REPORTED SHORTAGES OF
OFFICERS ACROSS THE STATE. BUT
WE UNDERSTAND THIS PROPOSAL DOES
NOT SEEK TO CRIMINALIZE PEOPLE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS THAT
WILL ALMOST INEVITABLY BE THE
RESULT. UNFORTUNATELY WE HAVE A
LOT OF LAWS ON THE BOOKS THAT
ARE ANTI HOMELESSNESS LAWS THAT
CRIMINALIZE SURVIVAL BUT
PUNISHING PEOPLE FOR DOING
THINGS THAT AMOUNT TO EXISTING
IN PUBLIC LIKE SITTING SLEEPING
AND LOITERING. AND ONCE AGAIN
LIKE EVERY OTHER ASPECT OF OUR
CRIMINAL LEGAL SYSTEM THE
ENFORCEMENT OF THESE LAWS
DISPROPORTIONATELY TARGETS BLACK
AND BROWN PEOPLE ON THE STREETS
. FINALLY PROVIDING EFFECTIVE
SERVICES AND SUPPORT REQUIRES
BUILDING TRUST AND UNFORTUNATELY
HOMELESS FOLKS HAVE OFTEN HAD
NEGATIVE INTERACTIONS WITH LAW
ENFORCEMENT WHICH LEADS TO A
LACK OF TRUST. THEREFORE
REQUIRING LAW ENFORCEMENT
PRESENCE ON THESE HOMELESS
OUTREACH TEAMS IS MORE LIKELY TO
HURT RATHER THAN HELP PEACE
EFFORTS IT WILL ALMOST CERTAINLY
RESULT. IN PEOPLE WHO NEED THE
OFFERED SERVICES REJECTING THEM
DUE TO THE ASSOCIATION WITH LAW
ENFORCEMENT. BECAUSE OF THIS THE
BILL MIGHT ACTUALLY HAVE THE
OPPOSITE OF IT STATED A FACT.
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT I BELIEVE
WE HAVE ONE MORE LEAD OPPOSITION
A WITNESS- SERRA REGNI. PLEASE
GO AHEAD GOOD MORNING COMMITTEE
MEMBERS AND SHARED MY NAME IS
SERRA REGNI I'M HERE ON BEHALF
OF AN ISSUE JUSTICE PATIENT
JUSTICE IS A STATEWIDE POLICY
NONPROFIT THAT WORKS TO ACTIVATE
THE POLITICAL POWER OF THOSE
DIRECTLY IMPACTED BY MASS
INCARCERATION. WE USE EVIDENCE
BASED ADVOCACY TO CREATE
SOLUTIONS THAT ENSURE TRUE
PUBLIC SAFETY FOR ALL OF US. I
WANT TO START BY EMPHASIZING
WHAT YOU'VE ALREADY HEARD TODAY.
REGARDLESS OF THE INTENTION
PLEASE INTERACTION WITH PEOPLE
WHO ARE EXPERIENCING HOUSES MASS
RESULTING CRIMINALIZATION NOT
ANY ACTUAL LONG TERM SOLUTIONS.
WHAT CALIFORNIA'S IN THE LARGEST
INCREASE IN HOUSES LESS OF ANY
STATE IN TWENTY TWENTY A SIX
POINT 8% JUMP WE NEED LONG TERM
SOLUTIONS. WE ENCOURAGE THE
COMMITTEE TO LOOK AT THE
PRAGMATIC HOUSING FIRST MODEL
WHICH IS RECOGNIZED BY
CALIFORNIA AS AN EFFECTIVE AN
EVIDENCE BASED PRACTICE. THIS
MODEL FOCUSES ON ESTABLISHING
SAFE SECURE AFFORDABLE AND
PERMANENT HOUSING BEFORE ASKING
PEOPLE TO WORK ON THEIR OTHER
CHALLENGES. THIS CENTER IS THE
EMPOWERMENT AND STABILITY
NECESSARY TO MAKE LASTING
CHANGE. THIS BASELINE STRUCTURE
HAS BEEN IMPLEMENTED IN NEW YORK
DENVER HOUSTON SEATTLE AND
ATLANTA. THIS BILL IS TREATING
SYMPTOMS INSTEAD OF ADDRESSING
THE ROOT CAUSES NECESSARY TO
MAKE LONG TERM PROGRESS IN
MEANINGFUL CHANGE. WE ENCOURAGE
YOU TO LOOK AT THE CAUSES OF
HOUSES NICE LIKE RENT SURVIVING
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE BEING FORMALLY
INCARCERATED OR AGING OUT OF THE
FOSTER CARE SYSTEM. THIS CHANGE
IS ONE OF THE NECESSARY STEPS
NEEDED TO MOVE AWAY FROM WHAT WE
KNOW DOESN'T WORK USING
CRIMINALIZATION AS A SOLUTION TO
PUBLIC SAFETY. WE URGE THE
COMMITTEE TO VOTE AGAINST THIS
MEASURE AND INVESTING TO PUBLIC
SAFETY FOR ALL OF US. THANK YOU
ALL FOR YOUR TIME. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MISS. BRITNEY WE'RE
NOT GOING TO MOVE ON TO
WITNESSES WAITING TO TESTIFY VIA
THE TELEPHONE CONFERENCE COULD
SERVICE. A MODERATE YOU WOULD
PLEASE FROM THE INDIVIDUALS
WAITING TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION
OF S. B. ONE ZERO ZERO SIX AND
WILL BEGIN. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION
TO S. B. ONE ZERO ZERO SIX
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO. ONE FILED BY ZERO AT THIS
TIME. MADAM CHAIR NOBODY IS
QUEUING UP. THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
HEY NOW WE'RE GONNA GO TO OUR
COMMITTEE MEMBERS HERE AND WE
HAVE A CENTER WIENER I THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MEMORIES CHAIR- SO I-
WHEN I FIRST SAW THIS BILL I HAD
THE SAME CONCERNS A SEMI
OPPONENT OPPOSITION WITNESSES
HAD ABOUT MAKING A SECURE I'M
VERY FOCUSED ON LAW ENFORCEMENT-
WHEN YEAH WE KNOW THE LAW
ENFORCEMENT IS. NOT THE SOLUTION
TO HOMELESSNESS AND INVITES- HAS
THE AUTHOR AND I DISCUSS WHEN WE
TALK TO POLICE OFFICERS-
CERTAINLY NOT WHAT THEY'RE
WANTING TO DO- THEY HAVE ACTUAL
CRIMES TO- TO SALT- AND SO- I
KNOW THAT THEIR AMENDMENTS I
BELIEVE AND- MADAM CONSULTANT
THAT. BUT WILL BE TAKEN ABOUT.
CONFORMING S TO THE STRUCTURE
OF THE- SANTIAGO BILL AS I READ
ABOUT THAT YES THAT IS CORRECT
AND I AM I AM ACCEPTING THOSE
MA'AM OKAY GREAT. IN ADDITION-
I'VE HAD CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
AUTHOR- BUT I THINK WERE IN
AGREEMENT DESPITE YOU CONFIRM-
RIGHT NOW THE BILL'S SPONSOR
SANTIAGO BILL HAD LIKE A MULTI
DISCIPLINARY TEAM GOING OUT TO
YOUR PUBLIC HEALTH PEOPLE.
OUTREACH WORKERS IT'S BETTER
PEOPLE WHO CAN ACTUALLY HELP
OFFER SERVICES TRY TO TRANSITION
PEOPLE OFF THE STREETS AND INTO
A STABLE SETTING GET THE HELP
THEY NEED- AND- THE BILL AND IS
CURRENTLY IS IN PRINT STATES
THAT A LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICER.
MUST BE PART OF THE TEAM AND MY
TAKE AS I'VE EXPRESSED TO THE
AUTHOR IS THAT THAT SHOULD BE
OPTIONAL- FOR COUNTIES COUNTY
SHALL BE OUT THERE MAY BE
SITUATIONS. WHERE I COUNTY
DECIDES THAT THEY DIDN'T WANT TO
HAVE LAW ENFORCEMENT PRESENT OR
AVAILABLE FOR IT BASED ON THE
CONTEXT BECAUSE THERE ARE A
MILLION DIFFERENT CONTACTS- BUT
THERE MAY BE SITUATIONS WHERE.
THEY EITHER DON'T WANT AN
OFFICER PRESIDENT OR THERE'S NO
OFFICER AVAILABLE BECAUSE OF
STAFFING- AND BENEFITS AND I
WOULD NOT WANT TO HAVE. YOU KNOW
COUNTY GETS A GRANT UNDER THIS
PROGRAM AND THEN THEY CAN ONLY
IMPLEMENT IT IF THEY'D LIKE POLL
PLEASE OFFICER OFF OF OFF OF THE
B. THAT SHOULD BE A RESOURCE
DECISION OF THE COUNTY MAKES AT
THE LOCAL LEVEL WE WANT TO GIVE
THEM- THAT FLEXIBILITY SO MY
TAKE IS. ON WHAT I WOULD ASK IS
THE IS THE AUTHOR WILLING TO
AMEND THE BILL WOULD BE TODAY
BUT AS IT MOVES TOWARDS APPROACH
IF IT GETS OUT OF COMMITTEE
TODAY- TO MAKE THE LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICER ASPECT.
OPTIONAL INSTEAD OF MANDATORY.
SURE THE- AND THANK YOU FOR THE-
AND WE- THIS YOU KNOW COLLEGE
THAT YOU KNOW OUR GOAL- AND I
HOPEFULLY LET. GOAL IS TO GET
THE RESOURCES TO THE STREET AS
FAST AS POSSIBLE AND AS
EFFICIENTLY AS POSSIBLE WITH AS-
LITTLE BUREAUCRACY AS POSSIBLE-
I CERTAINLY. DON'T WANT TO
PRESCRIBE TO THE COUNTIES-
EVERYTHING THAT THEY NEED TO DO
UNDER THIS SO IF THERE'S A WAY
WE CAN WORK THAT LANGUAGE INTO
THE BILL AND THE AND THE-
FUNDING STILL HAPPEN THEN
ABSOLUTELY I'M OPEN TO THAT. AND
I THINK YOU'RE RIGHT THE
COUNTIES CAN DECIDE FOR
THEMSELVES OF THE TEAMS CAN
DECIDE FOR THEMSELVES WHETHER
THEY ACTUALLY A LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICER THERE OR NOT. OKAY SO
THAT BY THE END OF THE SYSTEM TO
BE CLEAR- I THINK IT'S A PRETTY
SIMPLE- AND THAT MAN BECAUSE
THERE'S A SENSE OF SAYS I DON'T
HAVE IT IN FRONT OF ME I'M
SORRY- PRESS. DO YOU HAVE
INFORMATION. THE BILL DECKER AND
CURRENT FORM REQUIRES A LOT OF
HIS SENTENCES YEAH- AL WHICH
YOU'RE WHAT YOU'RE ASKING IS CAN
WE MAKE IT OPTIONAL AND I AM YES
I'M SAYING YES WE CONDUCT AN
OPTIONAL GREAT- I ALSO WANTED TO
CLARIFY THE AMENDMENTS TO LINK
IT TO THE SANTIAGO BILL CROSSED
ALREADY SO THAT'S IN THAT'S IN
THE BEDROOM BUT THIS AND THIS
AMENDMENT- IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING
FROM THE CONSULTANT WHO WORKED
ON IT THAT WOULD BE VERY EASY TO
YEAH. AND WE HAVE TO AND I THINK
WE HAVE PLENTY OF TIME YEAH THE
TIME TIME TO DO IT FOR I SAID ON
APPROPRIATIONS TO SELL THE
HOUSE- SO WITH WITHOUT CHANGE
THAT IT IT'S ALREADY BEEN
AMENDED TO CONFORM TO THE
SANTIAGO STRUCTURE AND MAKING
THE LONG FOR SOME PEACE OPTIONAL
TO ME THIS IS PROVIDING FNDING
TO COUNTIES TO PROVIDE MORE L.
REACH- TO GOD TO HELP HOMELESS
PEOPLE AND I FULLY AGREE THAT
THE FUNDAMENTAL SOLUTION TO
HOMELESSNESS IS- IT'S GOT MORE
HOUSING AND- KEEPING PEOPLE
STABLE IN HOUSING AND SO FORTH-
BUT I I'M GOING TO SUPPORT THE
BILL TODAY. WITH THE COMMITMENT
TO MAKE IT OUT PARTICULARS
CHANGE. THANK YOU SIR AND I
APPRECIATE. THE CENTER SKINNER.
THANK YOU- SORRY JONES I
APPRECIATE WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO
DO BECAUSE I KNOW THAT CURRENTLY
IT- EVEN THOUGH WE HAVE A NUMBER
OF CITIES AND COUNTIES WHO ARE
STARTING TO- TOGETHER
ALTERNATIVES FOR- IF A CALL
COMES IN. THAT RELATES TO A
HOMELESS INDIVIDUAL OR OTHER
INDIVIDUALS WHO MIGHT NEED
DIFFERENT KINDS OF ASSISTANCE
AND NOT REQUIRE LAW ENFORCEMENT
RESPONSE. HERE THAT'S STARTING
TO HAPPEN AND THERE'S ALSO PILOT
PROJECTS THAT THE BUDGET IS
FUNDED IT'S NOT YET UNIVERSAL OF
COURSE OR THAT YOU KNOW NEITHER
IF WE SET UP AN INFRASTRUCTURE
ADEQUATE. NOR IS THERE THE
STAFFING ADEQUATE OR THE FUNDING
ADEQUATE SO YOU KNOW CERTAINLY.
ALEX WAS THERE GOING TO COME
INTO LAW ENFORCEMENT. HOWEVER MY
THE ISSUES I HAVE ARE. IT BEHIND
NUMBER OF WOMEN YOU KNOW PERHAPS
THE DOWNFALL OF BEING A BUDGET
YEARS- IT. WILD DEER OBVIOUSLY
OUR DOJ. HAS A CERTAIN
RESPONSIBILITIES OVER A LONG
FORSMAN AGENCIES. WHEN I THINK
ABOUT WHERE WE MIGHT HOW SUCH
GRANT PROGRAM DOJ JUST BY ITS
NATURE. DID THE KIND OF STAFFING
IN SUCH IT HAS IS A FAR MORE
EXPENSIVE ENTITY TO YOU KNOW IF
IT IF THIS ACTION REQUIRES THEM
TO WORK AT YOU KNOW HAVE MORE
STAFF IT'S JUST IT'S JUST OF IT
JUST COSTS MORE SO THAT'S ONE
ISSUE. AND THEN ANOTHER ISSUE IS
THAT. THE YOU KNOW PART OF THE
INTENT HERE IS TO PROVIDE. THE
CARD TO SUPPORT STRUCTURES OR
THE RESPONSES THAT ARE JUST LAW
ENFORCEMENT. AND OF COURSE THAT
IS OBVIOUSLY NOT DOJ'S MILIEU
EITHER- SO IT DID I'M NOT SURE
IT'S APPROPRIATE TO REALLY URGE
I WANT TO SAY PROPRIOCEPTION OF
FEAR BUT RATHER IT IT'S BEST
SUITED. TO PLACE TODAY DOJ. AND
THEN- ADDITIONALLY WAIT. IF THE
GRANTS I GUESS I WOULD RATHER
SEE THE GRANT'S GOING TOWARDS
THE INFRASTRUCTURE THAT WOULD
ALLOW FOR. YOU KNOW FOR THE EVEN
THE CALLS TO GO TO A DIFFERENT
PLACE NOW I KNOW THAT YOU KNOW
AGAIN WE'RE IN THAT TRANSITION
BUT- SO I APPRECIATE. WHAT YOU
AND THE SPONSORS ARE TRYING TO
ACCOMPLISH. I'M NOT SURE IF I
CAN QUITE GET THERE IN THE WAY
IT'S CONSTRUCTED RIGHT NOW. OKAY
IF I CAN ADD TO TWO COMMENTS AND
I THINK THIS ACTUALLY CAUSES
SOME OF THE THINGS THE
OPPOSITION SAID TO. YOU KNOW IN
IN CALIFORNIA RIGHT NOW THE
HOMELESS SITUATION YOU KNOW I'M
I THINK WE ALL AGREES ADDING
EMERGENCY STATUS- THE-
DEPARTMENTS THE COMMITTEES.
ANALYSIS POINTS OUT THAT YOU
KNOW 30% OF AMERICANS HOMELESS
PEOPLE HERE IN CALIFORNIA
HUNDRED SIXTY EIGHT THOUSAND
PEOPLE- THE OPPOSITION CREATED
SOME VERY GOOD IDEAS- YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT SOME VERY GOOD
IDEAS. THERE THERE'S NOTHING IN
MY BILL THAT I WOULD EVER SAY IS
A- ONE SIZE FITS ALL OR IS THE
ULTIMATE SOLUTION OR THE FINAL
ANSWER. IT'S HOMELESSNESS IN
CALIFORNIA I MEAN E'VE GOT A
HUNDRED SIXTY EIGHT THOUSAND
PEOPLE THAT WE NEED TO IMPACT IN
A POSITIVE WAY. THIS IS JUST ONE
STEP ONE SMALL- BITE AT THE
ELEPHANT I GUESS- FOR LACK OF A
BETTER ANALOGY THAT- IS
PURPOSELY SET UP COMPETITIVELY
SO THE COUNTIES THAT WANT TO
PARTICIPATE IN THIS CAN'T
COMPETE FOR THE GRANT TO GET IT
IF THEY WANTED- AGAIN BACK TO
YOU KNOW SOME SALUTE IDEAS YOU
PRESENT AND THE OPPOSITION THOSE
ARE GOOD IDEAS TO LET'S DO.
LET'S DO ALL OF THEM LET'S LET'S
BE CREATIVE IN CALIFORNIA LET'S
LET THE COUNTIES. ALL WORK- AND
COME UP WITH SOLUTIONS THAT WORK
FOR THEIR COUNTY AND THEN AS
BEST WE CAN COMMUNICATE THOSE TO
THE OTHER COUNTIES. SO THAT THE
BEST IDEAS RISE TO THE TOP AND
THOSE ARE THE ONES THAT WE
INSTITUTED PROCESS STATE. I
THINK THAT THIS IS AGAIN IT IS A
SMALL AMOUNT OF MONEY IT'S A
SMALL COMPETITIVE GRANT THEN
AGAIN ALLOWS COUNTIES. TO
COMPETE FOR IT AND HAVE A
POSITIVE IMPACT ON THE ON THE
SEVERAL PEOPLE THAT THEY CAN
IMPACT IN A POSITIVE WAY WE
PICKED D. O. J. BECAUSE UNDER
OUR WITH OUR RESEARCH FELT LIKE
THEY HAD THE BEST A SYSTEM
ALREADY IN PLACE- THEY WERE MORE
ABLE TO DO IT PASSED THROUGH.
WITH THE GRANT FUNDING FROM THE%
STATE TO THE LOCAL JURISDICTIONS
WITHOUT HIS HAVING TO GEAR UP AS
MUCH AS MAYBE ANOTHER DEPARTMENT
WOULD HAVE TO DO I'M CERTAINLY
OPEN TO LOOKING AT OTHER
SOLUTIONS AS WELL. AND YOU KNOW
MAYBE WORKING ON ANOTHER BILL
THAT. DOES A DIFFERENT KIND OF
GRANT TO THE COUNTIES TO A
DIFFERENT DEPARTMENT. I THINK
THIS IS A GOOD FIRST STEP AND I
THINK THAT- AS HAS BEEN SHARED
BY ALL OF US LAW ENFORCEMENT IS
FRUSTRATED WITH THE SITUATION AS
WELL AND THEY'RE ASKING FOR HELP
AND I THINK THAT HELP COMES FROM
THE OTHER PROFESSIONALS ARE ON
THE TEAM. AND THAT PROVIDES A
SAFETY FOR THE TEAM TO PROVIDE
SAFETY FOR THE OFFICER WHEN
THERE'S MORE EYEBALLS ON THE
SITUATION- EVERYBODY. GETS TO.
PERFORMING THEIR FOR CAPACITY.
APOLOGIZE TO JUST LOST MY LITTLE
MICROPHONE. OKAY THEY'RE SORT OF
LIKE THE MIKE SILVERSTONE IT
JUST DOESN'T HAPPEN. YOUR P. IS
WITHOUT THE- FROM ON. OKAY HERE
WE GO- I GUESS IT'S JUST THE
THREE OF US SO I AM GOING TO-
MOVE FORWARD SO. IT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING THAT THIS BILL.
AND ACCORDING TO MY NOTES HERE
IT SAYS THE HOMELESS OUTREACH
TEAMS WOULD INCLUDE A MENTAL
HEALTH PROFESSIONAL COUNTY
WELFARE PRESENTED IN A LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICER- I IN THIS I
THINK WOULD BE MORE OF A
COMPLIMENTARY AS YOU MENTIONED
EARLIER MORE OF A COMPLIMENTARY
BILL TO ALL OTHER PROGRAMS THAT
WE HAVE IN PLACE- I WOULD I
WOULD DESCRIBE IT AS THAT AND
MORE OF A COMPLIMENTARY AT
PRACTICE. AND I HAVE TO- JUST
SHARE FROM MY EXPERIENCE- FROM
SPEAKING TO OUR LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT- OFFICERS AND
DIFFERENT CITIES WITHIN MY
DISTRICT THAT WE HAVE SOMETHING
SIMILAR IN PLACE- THROUGH SOME
OF OUR CITIES AND THEY HAVE BEEN
ACTUALLY VERY BENEFICIAL TO HAVE
SOMEBODY WITH A PROFESSIONAL
MENTAL HEALTH CARE- PREPARATION.
TO COME ALONG WHEN THEY'RE
DEALING WITH PEOPLE THAT ARE-
HAVE- MENTAL HEALTH OR
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH- ISSUES I
THINK THAT IT GIVES OUR LAW
ENFORCEMENT A LITTLE BIT OF
SECURITY KNOWING THAT THERE'S A
PROFESSIONAL THERE WITH THEM.
AND AND ALSO I THINK IT'S ALSO.
SORT OF AND A PROTECTIVE CITING
IT PROTECTS OUR OUR- MANY MANY.
CONSTITUENTS WERE PARTIALLY ARE
SUFFERING FROM BEHAVIOR HEALTH
SO I THINK IT'S A IT'S A GOOD
COMPLEMENTARY PROGRAM TAB IT'S A
THOUGHTFUL PROGRAM. AND YES WE
DO HAVE SHORTAGES- JUST DROP
CALIFORNIA. NEEDLESS TO SAY WHEN
IT COMES TO BEHAVIOR HEALTH-
PRACTITIONERS. AS WELL AS
FUNDING THROUGHOUT THE STATE SO
WE HAVE SOMETHING THAT WOULD
COMPLEMENT- MANY OF OUR PROGRAMS
THAT ARE. HELPING OUR BEHAVIOR
HEALTH- RESIDENCE- ARE LAW
ENFORCEMENT TO WORK IN IN IN
COMPANIONSHIP OR IN A
COMPLIMENTARY MATTER I THINK IS
AN EXCELLENT IDEA I WOULD
ACTUALLY APPRECIATE. AND NOTHING
IS PERFECT AND I ACT I
APPRECIATE THE COMMENT YOU SAID
THERE'S NOT A ONE SIZE FITS ALL
BUT THIS GIVES AN OPTION. FOR
COUNTIES TO HAVE. ACCESS TO
FUNDING THAT WILL ALLOW THEM TO
IMPLEMENT THIS PROGRAM IF IT
SUITS AND- THERE'S A NEED FOR
THEM IN IN OUR IN OUR IN OUR
COUNTY SO- I ACTUALLY LIKE TO BE
ADDED AS A CO AUTHOR ON THIS
BILL. AND IN AS I SAID EARLIER I
SEE IT MORE AS A COMPLEMENTARY
ADDITIONAL EFFORT TO SUPPLEMENT
WHAT WE HAD TO WORK WORKING
TOWARDS- SO THANK YOU SENATOR
JONES FOR THAT. AND ON THAT. END
DO WE HAVE ANY OTHER COMMENTS.
SOME OF. WITH WITH THE CAN TO
TAKE THAT AMOUNT IN
APPROPRIATIONS ON THE BILL
PERFECT- SENT JONES WHICH LIKE
TO CLOSE. THANK YOU MEMBERS AYE
APPRECIATE THE ROBUST DISCUSSION
AND- LOOKING FORWARD TO- ALL OF
US HAVING GOOD IDEAS TO
POSITIVELY IMPACT HOMELESSNESS
IN CALIFORNIAN ASK YOUR I. WILL.
AFFECT AND WE HAVE A MOTION FROM
SENATOR WINNER AND S. B. ONE
ZERO ZERO SIX- THANK YOU THE
BILL- NOW HAS BEEN MOVED IN THE
MOTION. SB ONE ZERO ZERO SIX TO
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS BRADFORD
OUR BRADFORD I'D TROUBLED BY
TROUBLE GUY COME WATER- KAMAGRA
UPLOADING SKINNER. SKINNER NOT
BURNING WINNER. WINNER I'D BILL
HAS THREE VOTES. PERFECT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH CONGRATULATIONS
SENATOR JONES THANK YOU. THANK
YOU CENTERS PROCEDURE SUPPORT.
WELCOME SENATOR BRADFORD YOU MAY
PRESENT YOUR HILL. S. B. ONE
ZERO THREE EIGHT CAMANCHE YEAR
AS WE WANT TO. R. S. B. TEN
THIRTY EIGHT WHICH WILL CONTINUE
TO PROHIBIT THE USE OF FACIAL
RECOGNITION BY LAW ENFORCEMENT
WITH BODY WORN CAMERA TECHNOLOGY
AND TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN THE
LEGISLATURE PASSED IN THE
GOVERNOR SIGNED AB TWELVE
FIFTEEN BUYS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
TEAM WHICH BANNED THE USE OF
FACIAL RECOGNITION TECHNOLOGY IN
CONNECTION WITH CAMERAS WORN OR
CARRIED BY LAW ENFORCEMENT. THE
BAN WAS- SET WITH SUNSET AND
TWENTY TWENTY THREE SINCE TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN LAW
ENFORCEMENT USE OF FACIAL
RECOGNITION TECHNOLOGY HAS
BECOME MORE WIDESPREAD AS WELL
AS GROWING CONCERNS ABOUT THE
SHORTCOMINGS IN THE SHOES
PROMINENT TECHNOLOGY COMPANIES
LIKE MICROSOFT AMAZON AND IBM
HAVE DECLINED TO SELL FACIAL
RECOGNITION SYSTEMS THE LAW
ENFORCEMENT IN SEPTEMBER TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. THE LOS ANGELES
TIMES REPORTED THAT THE LAPD HAD
USE FACIAL RECOGNITION SOFTWARE
NEARLY THIRTY THOUSAND TIMES
SINCE TWO THOUSAND AND NINE
DESPITE YEARS OF VAGUE AND
CONTRADICTORY INFORMATION THE
POTENTIAL FOR MISUSE IS HIGH IT
COULD FURTHER EXACERBATE RACIAL
INEQUITIES AND OUR CRIMINAL
pARE ONE HUNDRED TIMES MORE
LIKELY TO MEAN MISS ED
MISIDENTIFIED. I WOULD FACE
RECOGNITION THAN WHITE MEMBERS
MEMBERS OF THIS LEGISLATURE
INCLUDING ME- WAS IDENTIFIED AS
A CRIMINAL- DURING A
DEMONSTRATION- THE FACIAL
RECOGNITION IN TWO THOUSAND AND
NINETEEN- WENTY SIX LEGISLATORS
ALSO WHILE WERE IN THE DATABASE
AS CRIMINALS- DUE TO
MISIDENTIFICATION THIS BILL ARE
AIMS TO ADDRESS ONE SUSPECTS
SPECIFIC PART. OF THIS ISSUE
OFFICERS WORE BODY CAMERAS ARE
FUNDAMENTALLY INCAPABLE WITH
FACIAL RECOGNITION IN PART
BECAUSE OFFICERS ARE IN NEAR
CONSTANT BECAUSE A WIDE RANGE
ANGLE OF IMAGES IMAGES CALLS
BULLARD AND LOW QUALITY IMAGES
THAT FURTHER RESEARCH FALSE
MATCHES A WRONGFUL. ARRESTS
ACTION ON ONE OF THE LEAD FOR OF
BY CAM FOR LOG. STATED IN A
WRITTEN. BY THERE ARTIFICIAL
INTELLIGENCE- AT THE EXPORT
FACIAL RECOGNITION. TECHNOLOGY
IS NOT CURRENTLY RELIABLE ENOUGH
TO F. ETHICALLY JUSTIFY THE USE
OF BODY WORN CAMERAS AT LEAST
FACE RECOGNITION TECHNOLOGY
SHOULD NOT BE DEPLOYED UNTIL THE
TECHNOLOGY PERFORMED. WITH FAR
GREATER ACCURACY AND PERFORMS
EQUALLY WELL ACROSS RACES
ETHNICITIES GENDERS AND OTHER
IDENTITY GROUPS THIS BILL IS NOT
ABOUT LIMITING TOOLS WHICH LAW
ENFORCEMENT CAN USE IT'S ABOUT
ENSURING THAT TOO THAT THEY USE
ARE RELIABLE AND A COUPLE. OF
TESTIFIED ON IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL TODAY IS MATT CACKLE- STAFF
ATTORNEY FOR ACLU OF NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA AND- HE WILL ANSWER
ANY TECHNICAL QUESTIONS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANK
YOU SENATOR BRAD WILL NOW MOVE
ON TO- OUR WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
HERE ARE. IS NOT ON THE LINE OR
IS IN PERSON. BUILT ON A LIE
OKAY PERFECT PLEASE- PROCEED.
THE MORNING CARE NUMBERS MY NAME
IS MATT CABLE IN THE TOP TWENTY
WITH A HUGE BILL YOU LEARNING
CALIFORNIA MY WORK FOCUSES ON
ISSUES AT THE INTERSECTION-
MAINLAND AND CIVIL RIGHTS. AND
I'M SPEAKING FROM CAN SUPPORT
TODAY AS SB TEN THIRTY EIGHT AT
THREE TEN THIRTY MAKES PERMANENT
AN ESSENTIAL CIVIL RIGHTS LAW
THAT PROTECTS CALIFORNIA. NEARLY
THREE YEARS EXISTING ON
SUCCESSFULLY PROTECT PREVENTING
THE HARM THAT FACE. EVERYONE
SOMEBODY CAN BY PROTECTING
PRIVACY SAFEGUARDING OUR FREEDOM
OF SPEECH HOPING THE PREVENTION
OF MULTIPLE DATABASES AND
HELPING PREVENT THE
MISIDENTIFICATION AND WRONGFUL
IMPRISONMENT IMPRISONMENT OF
CALIFORNIA. CALIFORNIA MAKING
SURE THESE PROTECTION DO NOT
THANK THE IN TWENTY TWENTY THREE
. FACIAL RECOGNITION HAS NO
PLACE ON OFFICER BODY CAMERAS
BODY CAMERAS WERE INTENDED TO
GUARD AGAINST POLICE MISCONDUCT
NOT AT THE SURVEILLANCE SYSTEM
FOR THE POLICE TO IDENTIFY AND
TRACK CALIFORNIANS. I MEAN FACE
SCANNING TECHNOLOGY TO BODY
CAMERAS WOULD AUTOMATE THE
FORCIBLE IDENTIFICATION AND
PASILA TATE THE CREATION OF
DATABASES THAT IMMIGRANT CASES.
EITHER THE SAME DATABASES THAT I
COULD ALREADY DEMANDED ACCESS TO
IN OTHER STATES. SB TEN THIRTY
WILL CONTINUE TO PREVENT CLOGS
FACE AND BODY TRACKING SYSTEM
FROM BEING USED AGAINST
CALIFORNIA. SINCE THE CURRENT
LAW WAS ENACTED FEDERAL RESEARCH
HAS CONTINUED TO SHOWCASE A
RECOGNITION SOFTWARE IN AN
ACCURATE AND BY. GENERATING UP
TO ONE HUNDRED TIMES MORE CALLED
HOUSES BUT WOMEN AND PEOPLE OF
COLOR. ONES HAVE NOT BEEN
ELIMINATED FROM THE TECHNOLOGY
IN OTHER STATES THAT PERMIT THE
USE OF FACIAL RECOGNITION
MULTIPLE BLACK MEN HAVE BEEN
SUBJECTED TO WRONGFUL ARREST.
RESEARCH ALSO SHOWS THAT SKEWED
AND CONSTANT MOVEMENT INHERENT
IN BODY CAMERA FOOTAGE RAISES
THE RISK OF THESE FALSE
POSITIVES. PROMINENT TECH
COMPANIES SUCH AS AMAZON
MICROSOFT AND IBM HAVE REFUSED
TO SELL FACIAL RECOGNITION TO
LAW ENFORCEMENT. AND AXON THE
LARGEST BODY CAMERA MANUFACTURER
HAS REFUSED TO ADD FACIAL
RECOGNITION TO WITH THE POLICE
DEVICES. ALL CALIFORNIANS SHOULD
BE WORRIED ABOUT FACIAL
RECOGNITION ON BODY CAMERAS. BUT
THE RISKS ARE PARTICULARLY ACUTE
IN COMMUNITIES WHERE POLICE
MISCONDUCT REGULARLY THREATENS
THE SAFETY OF BLACK PEOPLE
LATINOS AND IMMIGRANTS. THIS
BILL ENSURES THE CONTINUED
PROTECTION OF CIVIL RIGHTS FOR
THESE COMMUNITIES AND ALL
CALIFORNIANS. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
THE COMMITTEE TO VúI ON SB TEN
THIRTY EIGHT. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MISTER CARROLL- WE
WILL NOW BEGIN WITH ANY
WITNESSES HERE IN THE ROOM DO WE
HAVE ANY WITNESSES PLEASE
PROCEED THANK YOU. KERN MEMBERS
CATALINA SANCHEZ WITH CORBIN AND
KAISER REPRESENTING THE
ELECTRONIC FRONTIER FOUNDATION
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL THANK YOU
. DANYCH ORDER AMOUNT BEHALF OF
THE SAN FRANCISCO PUBLIC
DEFENDER IN STRONG SUPPORT.
SERIK ME I'M HAVE INITIATE
JUSTICE IN STRONG SUPPORT. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH I BELIEVE THAT IS
ALL THE WITNESSES HERE- NOW
WE'LL GET IT GOING TO MOVE TO
UNTIL WITNESSES WAITING TO
TESTIFY THE OTHER TELECONFERENCE
OR BEST MOCK MODERATOR IF YOU
WOULD PLEASE FROM THE
INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF S. B. WHEN. OUR
TEN THIRTY EIGHT. TESTIFYING IN
SUPPORT FOR SB TEN THIRTY EIGHT
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO AT THIS TIME WHEN FILED BY
pWE WILL LINE TWENTY FIVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS CURRENTLY WITH THE
CALIFORNIA NURSES. ASSOCIATION
COMES APART SB TEN THIRTY EIGHT
THANK YOU. SIX WE WERE LINE
TWENTY TWO YOU ARE OPEN.
SEMENTARA BEHALF OF SMART JEFF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. ONE MOMENT WE HAVE A COUPLE
MORE QUEUING UP LOCAL LINE
SIXTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI JADI
ON SAY WITH BROKEN PREGNANCY
WITH STRONG SUPPORT FOR SB TEN
THIRTY. KAMLAGER LINE THIRTY
FOUR YOU ARE OPEN. GOOD MORNING
THIS IS KAELIN DAN CALLING IT A
PROUD SPONSOR FROM ACLU
CALIFORNIA ACTION ALSO CALLING
TO REGISTER SUPPORT FROM LESLIE
CALDWELL HOUSTON OF THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION THANK YOU. I'M SURE
THERE ARE NO OTHER PARTICIPANTS
QUEUED UP AT THIS TIME. THANK
YOU MR MODERATOR IF YOU WOULDN'T
MIND CHECKING THE LINES JUST ONE
MORE TIME JUST TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE'VE HEARD FROM ALL AB. LEAD
SUPPORT WITNESSES I MEAN SUPPORT
WITNESSES. AND AS A REMINDER
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT. AT THIS TIME. ONE
MOMENT WE DO HAVE ONE QUEUING UP
. IN TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
PLEASE PRESS ONE ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME AND WE WILL GO TO LINE
THIRTY FIVE YOU ARE OPEN. GOOD
MORNING LESLIE CALDWELL HOUSTON
FOR THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION. OR THANK
YOU. AND NOBODY ELSE IS QUEUED
UP HER SUPPORT OF SB ONE ZERO
ZERO. ACR NINETY SIX. THANK YOU
MR MODERATOR HAVING HEARD FROM
ALL SUPPORTERS WILL NOT FOLLOW
THE SAME PROCESS IN HERE FROM-
ANY OPPOSITION. AND WE DO HAVE
ONE LEAD OPPOSITION WITNESS
HOOSIER MUSLIM. I'M IS CHAIR
MEMBERS AND SHAUN MUTCHLER ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
SHERIFFS ASSOCIATION ABOUT
RESPECTFUL IN OPPOSITION TO S.
B. AT TEN THIRTY EIGHT- WHICH
WOULD PERMANENTLY EXTEND THE
TEMPORARY PROHIBITS XIN ON LAW
ENFORCEMENT'S USE OF BIOMETRIC
SURVEILLANCE TECHNOLOGY- WHICH
INCLUDES FACIAL RECOGNITION IN
OFFICER CAMERAS- FROM A GENERAL
POLICY PERSPECTIVE WE ARE
CONCERNED ABOUT THE LEGISLATURE
CONTINUING. TO DEPRIVE LAW
ENFORCEMENT OF TOOLS THAT COULD
POTENTIALLY PROTECT THE PUBLIC
SAFETY AND EIGHT INVESTIGATIONS.
IF THERE ARE JUSTIFIABLE
CONCERNS ABOUT PARTICULAR
TECHNOLOGIES AND THEIR USAGE
DISCUSSIONS AMONG LOCAL
COMMUNITIES LOCAL AGENCIES AND
THE STAKEHOLDERS CAN BE HAD-
HOWEVER TO MAKE PERMANENT WHAT
IS EFFECTIVELY A BLANKET BAN ON
PARTICULAR TECHNOLOGY- LIMITS
LAW ENFORCEMENT'S FXE AND
RESTRICTS ITS ABILITY TO MEET
ITS INVESTIGATORY. AND CRIME
PREVENTION AND SOLVING MANDATES-
OFFICER CAMERAS DO MORE THAN
FOSTER ALONE FORSMAN
ACCOUNTABILITY ARE THEY CAN
PROVIDE MEANINGFUL INVESTIGATIVE
ASSISTANCE IN IDENTIFYING
SUSPECTS AND EXONERATING ON
INVOLVED PERSONS. AND WITH THE
RISE IN ACTIVE SHOOTER EVENTS
AND BRAZEN THEFTS IN PUBLIC
SPACES- CONCERNING BANDS ON
TOOLS THAT COULD ASSIST OFFICERS
AND PROTECT PUBLIC SAFETY- WE
BELIEVE IS SHORT SIGHTED FOR
THESE REASONS WE RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR HIS PERSONAL I BELIEVE
IS THE ONLY LEAD OPPOSITION THAT
WE HAVE ON RECORD WE WILL NOW
MOVE ON TO WITNESSES WAITING TO
TESTIFY VIA THE TELECONFERENCE
ORVIS. MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD
PLEASE PROVIDE THE INDIVIDUALS
WAITING TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION
OF S. B. TEN THIRTY EIGHT WILL
BEGIN. THANK YOU OR TO EXPRESS
OPPOSITION FOR SB TEN THIRTY
EIGHT PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME. ONE ZERO TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION. TO TEN THIRTY
EIGHT. ANNOUNCER MEMBERS LEVINE
SHERMAN WITH THE RIVERSIDE
SHERIFF'S ASSOCIATION OFF TODAY
REPRESENTING POLICE OFFICERS
PROFICIENT CLAREMONT CORONA.
POMONA READY NEWPORT BEACH. AND
THEN IN THE BANK IN THE WORLD
ARCADIA RIVERSIDE HORTON CITY
AND ANGELES POLICE OPPOSITION TO
THE BLANKET BAN ON THE
TECHNOLOGY THANK. ON THE PHONE
LINES TO PRESS ONE ZERO TWO
EXPRESS OP FOR. THIS WITH PRESS
ONE THIS. FOR TEN THIRTY EIGHT.
RENDON HERE NOBODY IS QUEUING.
THANK YOU MISTER MODERATE IF YOU
WOULD PLEASE CHECK POINTS ONE
MORE TIME JUST TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE'VE HAD AN OPPORTUNITY TO HEAR
FROM ALL OUR OPPOSITION-
WITNESSES. ABSOLUTELY AS MADAM
CHAIR SAID PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
AT THIS TIME TO EXPRESS
OPPOSITION TO ONE ZERO THREE
EIGHT THE STOCK. I NOBODY IS
GOING UP. THANK YOU MR MODERATOR
AND THANK YOU TO ALL OUR SUPPORT
IN A POSITION WITNESSES WILL NOT
BRING THE DISCUSSION BACK TO OUR
MEMBERS TO ANY OF OUR MEMBERS
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
WE HAVE- A MOTION TO MOVE THE
BILL BY SENATOR WIENER. ANYONE
ELSE. PERFECT I DO HAVE- SOME
STATEMENTS THAT I WOULD LIKE TO
MAKE- AND I'M GRATEFUL FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE HERE AND BE
ABLE TO SPEAK ON THIS BILL AND
I'M A FIRM BELIEVER IN THE RIGHT
PROCESS. THE RIGHT TO DUE
PROCESS AND BELIEVE THAT WHEN WE
CHARGE AND CONVICT PEOPLE IN
THIS COUNTRY IT SHOULD BE
BECAUSE THE EVIDENCE IS CLEAR.
WHILE I UNDERSTAND THAT POOL
WHILE I UNDERSTAND FULLY THAT
THE CONCERN THAT THIS BILL
ATTEMPTS TO ADDRESS I FIND THE
CORE ISSUE OF THIS BILL TO BE
WITH HUMAN ERROR. FACIAL
RECOGNITION TECHNOLOGY SHOWS
PROMISE AS A TOOL FOR LAW
ENFORCEMENT BUT SHOULD NEVER BE
USED AS A SUBSTITUTE FOR
ESTABLISHING IDENTITY THROUGH
FINGERPRINTS. AND DNA. I DO NOT
THINK THAT IT IS APPROPRIATE TO
PUT IN PLACE A PERMANENT BAN. ON
THE USE OF FACIAL RECOGNITION
SOFTWARE ON BODY CAMERAS AT THIS
TIME WE HAVE BEEN GIVEN EVEN
GIVEN THE TECHNOLOGY THE ABILITY
TO ADVANCE AND IMPROVE. WE'RE
MAKING ASSUMPTIONS BASED ON WHAT
MIGHT OCCUR WITH THE FUTURE
EVOLUTION OF THIS TECHNOLOGY IN
LIEU OF MAKING THIS TECHNOLOGY
MORE EFFECTIVE THE BILL WILL
INSTEAD KIRBY INNOVATION OF
FACIAL RECOGNITION TECHNOLOGY
WHICH HAS SHOWN GREAT PROMISE IN
SOME INSTANCES. OF BEING AN
EFFECTIVE TOOL FOR PROTECTING
THE PUBLIC. MY STAFF MET WITH
THE GROUP WHO SPOKE OF HOW THIS
TECHNOLOGY HAS BEEN USED TO
IDENTIFY A SERIAL CHILD RAPIST
AND ALLOW POLICE TO SAVE THAT
YOUNG CHILD FROM A TERRIBLE
SITUATION. WE SHOULD FOCUS ON
ADDRESSING THE OBVIOUS FLAWS IN
FACIAL RECOGNITION AND BIOMETRIC
SCANNING SOFTWARE IN ORDER TO
CREATE A BETTER SYSTEM. THAT
BALANCES THE PROTECTION OF THE
PUBLIC WITH ESSENTIAL RIGHTS TO
PRIVACY. FREEDOM AND DUE
PROCESS. RATHER THAN PERMANENTLY
BANNING THESE POTENTIAL. OUT
USEFUL TECHNOLOGIES WE SHOULD
FOCUS ON REGULATING THEIR USE IN
AN EFFORT TO PROTECT THE
PRIVACY. AND LIBERTIES OF OUR
CONSTITUENTS WITHOUT SACRIFICING
THE F. IF EFFICACY OVERSTATES
PUBLIC SAFETY NETWORKS FOR THE
RE REFER FOR THESE REASONS I
CANNOT SUPPORT THIS BILL TODAY.
ON THAT END SENATOR COME UP OR
WOULD YOU LIKE TO HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK. NO. OKAY
WE HAVE A MOTION BY CENTERS THAT
WE WILL HAVE. CONSULTANT PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL THE SCHOOLS. I
APOLOGIZE CENTER PROFFER YES
PLEASE THANK YOU THIS BILL HAS
NOTHING TO DO WITH DILLON WHAT
WHAT MIGHT OCCUR IT SPECIFICALLY
DEALS WITH WHAT HAS OCCURRED AND
IT'S TO AN ACCURACY OF BODY CAM
FACIAL RECOGNITION THIS BILL
DOES NOTHING TO PREVENT LAW
ENFORCEMENT FROM USING STANDARD
FACIAL RECOGNITION AND A
DATABASE OF IDENTIFYING SUSPECTS
AS IS BEING USED ALL ACROSS THIS
COUNTRY IT DOESN'T STIFLE
INNOVATION WHATSOEVER THIS BILL
ADDRESSES WHAT YOUR CONCERNS
ARE. ALLOWING THE TECHNOLOGY TO
EVOLVE TO THE POINT WHERE IT IS
RELIABLE RIGHT NOW AGAIN TWENTY
SIX MEMBERS OF THIS LEGISLATURE
INCLUDING ME WAS IDENTIFIED AS A
CRIMINAL USING BODY CAL FACIAL
RECOGNITION THE- PITCHERS. AND
IMAGES THAT ARE CAPTURED ON A
BODY CAMERA ARE NOWHERE NEAR THE
SAME AS A STEEL ARE HELD UP
CAMERA TAKING A PICTURE OF
SOMEONE IT IS A DIFFUSED PITCHER
AT AT STATED MANY TIMES
OFFICERS. ARE IN CONSTANT
MOVEMENT SO IT'S BETTER TO ERR
ON THE SIDE OF CAUTION WHICH
THIS BILL CLEARLY IS TRYING TO
DO IT DOES NOT STIFLE LEGACY
INNOVATION IN ANY KIND OF WAY IT
DOESN'T LIMIT THE ABILITY OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT IT. CREATES THE
PUBLIC SAFETY IN WHICH MANY
MEMBERS SAY THEY'RE CONCERNED
BECAUSE AGAIN IF IT WAS YOUR SON
OR DAUGHTER OR YOURSELF WHO IS
IDENTIFIED AS A CRIMINAL I THINK
YOU WOULD BE CONCERNED AS WELL
THE FOR THOSE REASONS AND THOSE
REASONS AND MANY MORE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR- VOTE
. THANK YOU VERY MUCH CENTER
BRADFORD- THE- CANCEL PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. SB TEN THIRTY
EIGHT BRADFORD. BRADFORD DIETRO
BOKE NO TROUBLE NO COM LONGER
AYE COMMANDER AYE SKINNER.
SKINNER AYE WIENER. WIENER AYE
AND THE VOTE IS FORTY ONE. THE
BILL IS OUT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
SENATOR BRADFORD AND
CONGRATULATIONS. S. B. NINE
SIXTEEN LEYVA COM LONGER. FROM
LONGER I'VE FIVE ZERO AND THAT
IS IT.
OKAY. MEMBERS ARE CONCLUDES OUR
AGENDA FOR THE DAY I WANT TO
THANK ALL THE INDIVIDUALS WHO
PARTICIPATED AND PUBLIC
TESTIMONY TODAY IF YOU ARE NOT
ABLE TO TESTIFY TODAY PLEASE
SUBMIT YOUR COMMENTS AND
SUGGESTIONS IN WRITING TO THE
PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE OR VISIT
OUR WEBSITE YOUR COMMENTS AND
SUGGESTIONS ARE IMPORTANT TO US
AND WE WANT TO INCLUDE YOUR
TESTIMONY AN OFFICIAL HEARING
RECORD I WANT TO AGAIN THANK
YOU- AND WE APPRECIATE YOUR
PARTICIPATION HOW I WANT TO
THANK EVERYONE FOR YOUR PATIENCE
AND COOPERATION IN THIS
CONCLUDES OUR CHEN OF SENATE
PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE. AND WE
STAND ADJOURNED. YEAH.